So früh schon ja, heute schon, komm ich mach auch nicht so lang, ich mach heute auch nicht
so lange, ich will danach noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen spielen, exellent, gerade mal den chat
refreshen, weil ich gerade keine viewer zahlen sehe und im prinzip eigentlich nichts funktioniert
auf twitch, so jetzt refresht und schon funktioniert es, fast wie unter windows
was passiert heute denn so, das hängt ein bisschen von ab, das hängt ein bisschen von ab, was wir
davon machen, also ich muss übrigens gerade mal meine vm anmachen, dass der chrome weiter
kompiliert, das kann er ja nebenbei machen, das ist jetzt ja erstmal wurscht, das hat ja mit
heute was wir sonst machen nichts zu tun, er soll mal in ruhe chrome weiter kompilieren,
während wir was anderes machen, also, warum hat windows das jetzt resettet, soll er nicht,
nicht resetten windows, so heute kein plan, nicht so richtig, naja bisschen, bisschen, ich wollte euch
nämlich noch was fragen, guck mal es geht weiter, der sebaro hat es mir nicht geglaubt, dass man
einfach die vm einfrieren kann, der macht weiter, aber was weiß das sebaro schon, warum resettet
windows das bild, windows was ist los, ok, keine ahnung, juckt mich auch nicht, so, ich spiel pega,
ihr wisst ja was, ich bin gerade müde, ich weiß auch nicht, das will ich mal gucken, bin ich mal
gespannt was sie dazu sagen, ich habe nämlich heute morgen die halbe kampagne gespielt,
es hat übelst bock gemacht, und zwar, können wir uns mal bitworn unter docker anschauen,
aber machen, das ist eh eine gute idee, password manager anschauen, was mir da gefällt von,
das können wir echt machen, das können wir tatsächlich machen, das ist eine gute idee,
hast du dich schon mal in wifi 6 beschäftigt, außer dass es bessere namen hat als usb, bzw.
die endlich ihre sachen ordentlich benennen im vergleich zu dem was das usb forum macht,
nee, ich weiß, also ich habe mal in einem video ein bisschen drüber gelabert, also ich kann mich
da gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern, was ich mir damals angeguckt habe, irgendwie maximal ist
irgendwie 1,3 g oder so glaube ich was da maximal drüber geht, irgendwie so war das doch, was aber
in der praxis ähnlich erreicht wird, und also ich weiß auch wo ich mich damit beschäftigt habe,
war die sache halt so, das ding hieß schon wifi 6 bevor das standard überhaupt verabschiedet wurde,
und die standards, die wlan standards, die heißen ja acht immer, was 802 wlan 11n oder sowas in
der richtung, bis ac und hast du nicht gesehen, naja, und sonst habe ich eigentlich keine ahnung mehr
davon warum, also brauchen tut man es nicht wirklich, das ganze netzwerkzeug heißt 802
irgendwas, wirklich brauchen tut man es nicht, und heute morgen ist mir aber wieder eine sache
aufgefallen, ich habe es ja auch schon auf twitter geschrieben, und zwar, ich will mir
unbedingt einen neuen rechner kaufen, aber ich kann mir keinen neuen rechner kaufen, weil es
gibt nichts, sowas hatte ich noch nie, ich mein guck mal mein rechner ist von 2017,
wo ist er denn, ja guck mal oktober 2017, der rechner ist jetzt, sagen wir mal drei
jahre alt, wir runden mal ein bisschen auf, wir kompilieren immer noch nebenbei chromium, aber
das machen wir heute nicht, hauptsächlich im stream, habt ihr es gesehen, mein rechner ist
von ende 2017, also runden wir auf drei jahre alt, so, und es kann nicht sein, dass, dass ich einen
rechner kaufe vor drei jahren, dort noch die grafikkarte eingebaut habe, aus dem alten rechner,
und der nach drei jahren immer noch eines der schnellsten systeme ist, die es gibt,
das kann doch nicht sein, was ist denn da los, also das ist eine sache, die es früher definitiv
nicht gegeben hätte, früher hätte ich nach zwei jahren meinen rechner wegschmeißen können,
und mir einen neuen kaufen können, und ich muss mal sagen, damals hat es mich abgefuckt, wenn ich
mir dann, also so 2000 oder so, oder 2000 bis 2000, 2008 oder so rum, neun rechner kaufen musste,
alle zwei, das hat mich abgefuckt, aber jetzt ist es so, also mich hat es damals abgefuckt,
weil ich mir das nicht leisten konnte, und jetzt ist es so, jetzt habe ich mehr als genug kohle
dafür, und jetzt gibt es keine neue hardware, ich kann mir nichts neues kaufen, es gibt nichts,
also nichts was sich lohnt, ich will mir auch nichts sinnloses kaufen, so und
jetzt habe ich das problem, ich wollte mir letztes jahr schon ein ryzen system kaufen,
aber das lohnt sich nicht, der 8700k und die 1080ti ist einfach, ist einfach schnell genug,
man könnte fast sagen, die 1080ti war zu schnell, als sie rausgekommen ist, so und jetzt bringen
wir, wir gucken uns gleich mal ein video an, über den neue intel, über den 1900k von intel, wo habe
ich nämlich eben gerade gesehen, wo intel cheated bei benchmarks, richtig big brain logik, das muss
ich euch gleich mal zeigen, das video, so und ich will mir einen neuen rechner kaufen, aber es geht
nicht, und jetzt habe ich mir überlegt, ok, ende des jahres ist es ja wohl soweit, wie gesagt,
mir juckt es voll in den fingern, ich kann es kaum erwarten, dass nvidia eine 3700ti und amd
irgendwie einen 4950x rausbringt, also gerüchte, gerüchteweise ist es ja so, dass amd das nvidia
gegen ende des jahres was rausbringen will, so september, und wieso nicht auf ddr5 direkt
warten, naja weil sonst wartest du ja ewig, ich denke mal, dass aber das ein sprung ist,
der sich wenigstens halbwegs lohnt, sollte eigentlich 2021 passieren, man kann raten,
man kann viel raten, wenn der tag lang ist, das kann man schlecht sagen, genau das video,
das fand ich echt gut gemacht, obwohl ich sagen muss, pc welt videos ist ja normalerweise eher
so ein, geh weg, aber so, also und wenn wir uns mal überlegen, dass sie es vielleicht schaffen,
im september was rauszubringen, dann sind die neuen cpus wahrscheinlich so im december dann
auch erhältlich und vielleicht auch schon die etwas bessere variante, so und dann kaufe ich
mir was, weil wenn, wenn es amd wirklich schafft, so irgendwie den ryzen 4900 oder so rauszubringen,
muss ja nicht gleich in 4950 sein, in 4900 und nvidia 3080 ti, warum habe ich eigentlich
3070 ti geschrieben, ich meine 380 ti, was auch immer, 380 ti rausbringt, ja dann dürften
es schon so, ich hoffe mal so auf ungefähr 30, 30% vielleicht, 30-40%, 40 ist aber schon
glaube ich eher nicht, 30% leistungssteigung vielleicht so, für 30% hätte man sich 2000
kaputt gelacht, nach 2 jahren war der rechner 3 mal so schnell, äh ne ne echt nix, ja also
es ist echt, es ist echter wahnsinn, jetzt wo ich die kohle hab, kann ich mir keine neue hardware
kaufen, weil es nix gibt, wahnsinn und es ist ja so, es gibt ja noch nicht mal mehr die
möglichkeit heutzutage zu sagen, ich mache mir ein sli system, weil sli systeme funktionieren
nicht richtig und sind kacke, hätten die, hätten die den kram wenigstens mal ordentlich
und würden die den kram mal ordentlich unterstützen und hätten das die letzten jahre ordentlich
ausgebaut, dann könnte man wenigstens sagen, ja dann kaufe ich mir halt jetzt ein ryzen
system und mach 2 grafikkarten rein, ja das ist dann wenigstens ordentlich viel schneller,
aber nein sli systeme sind auch kacke, es gibt keine möglichkeit, ich kann kein geld
für hardware ausgeben, das ist nicht möglich, die ich weiß die probleme möchten wir erstmal
haben ja, aber es gibt nix, es gibt nix, schlimm, echt schlimm, worum gehts, ich lasse mich
grad drüber aus, dass ich geld ausgeben will für neue hardware und ich kann nicht, und
ich kann nicht, weil es gibt nix, es lohnt sich nichts ansatzweise mal, nix, so ähm
übrigens ich muss euch mal ein übelst lustiges video zeigen, äh vielleicht finde auch nur
ich das lustig, wartet mal, wartet mal, bestes video, geht bloß 19 sekunden, ja das ist
das lustige, ich kann mich einfach wieder wegfissen, alter, ich kann mich wieder wegfissen,
das ist so geil, ich kann mir das echt 50 mal angucken, vor allem das ist so gut auch
zusammengeschnitten hier, wie grad an hoch gucken, ja, das ist so geil, so was, so, so
was bescheuertes oder, oh man, naja, was auch immer, ich weiß nicht, warum ich auf youtube
neuerdings so ein kram empfohlen kriege, ne, diese ganze risitas-geschichte ist ja schon
total out, die ist immer, immer, immer innen irgendwo, ja, aber eigentlich die große zeit
hat sie jetzt hinter sich, wo es so bekannt war, aber warum krieg ich den kram jetzt auf
einmal vorgeschlagen, was, nein, so und ich hab mir nämlich grad das video hier angeguckt
und hab festgestellt, intel bescheißt, das wusste ich auch nicht, die bescheißen voll
bei benchmarks, also bescheißen, ich mein die benchmarkergebnisse stimmen aber sie sind
nicht reproduzierbar, das können wir uns gleich mal angucken, fand ich, hat mich echt
gewundert, früher hätte man da gesagt, hier intel, das ist ja schon irgendwie schon fast
irreführend oder so, das juckt anscheinend kein, das ist nicht das erste mal das intel
miese tricks absieht, ja das stimmt, und chrome, chrome, chrome, hey, etu, ja also gucken wir
mal das video, wo hab ichs denn hier, da, ich hab übrigens keine ahnung wer das ist,
es ist, es ist, der bauer light, nee, keine ahnung, irgendein pc welt man, oh sorry, ich
weiß nicht ob es ein man ist, ja ja es ist pc welt, es ist echt pc welt, ich weiß nicht,
normalerweise ist pc welt jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn an videos, aber alles besser als
chip, hat chip, moment, hab ich noch nie geguckt, hat chip einen youtube channel, oh je, ich
ahne schlimmes, chip hat einen youtube channel, ok, den interessiert aber kein mensch, ja
es ist tatsächlich, aber die da für den intro, das ist absurd, wenn man bedenkt, dass intel
sich vor drei jahren über einem d noch lustig gemacht hat, dass sie quasi auf zusammengeklebte
chips setzen und dann auch noch markiert hat, dass die zwei generationen die taktraten nicht
erreicht hat, das war im single core vor allem, und jetzt mehr oder weniger auf das gleiche
zug, also eins von weg, aber das war bescheuert von intel, letztendlich was funktioniert und
nicht abkackt oder so ist legitim, hatten werden erreicht, aber halt nur unter besonderen voraussetzungen
und genau deswegen werfen wir jetzt einen kurzen blick auf die spezifikationen, die
comet league s prozessoren setzen auf eine ja schon etwas überholte chip architektur
nämlich von skylake s aus dem jahr 2015, damaliges topmodell, der 6700k mit vier kerne,
ist eigentlich schon beeindruckend, wie es intel geschafft hat, daraus aus dem vier kerner
jetzt 10kh, das ist im prinzip mehr oder weniger meine cpu mit bisschen mehr kerne, intel schafft
seit fünf jahren nichts neues rauszubringen, 20 frets zu machen, immerhin 20 megabyte l3
cache und im single core immerhin 5,3 gigahertz und all core sogar immerhin auch 4,9 gigahertz,
also das ist eigentlich schon beeindruckend, dahinter stecken jetzt übrigens zwei techniken,
also zumindest beim single core, nämlich einmal der turbo boost max 3.0, der besagt aus, dass
die cpu automatisch erkennt, welche beiden cores am performansten quasi arbeiten und
auf diesen erhöht die cpu automatisch an den tag auf bis zu 5,2 gigahertz, obendrauf, gibt
es dann eben noch einen ganz neuen, der ist ein thermal velocity boost, der kann, sofern
die cpu unter 17 grad celsius läuft, noch einmal 100 megahertz obendrauf packen, der
kann, was für ein boost, die haben auch immer, wer hat eigentlich dieses hintergrundbild
gemacht, das ist irgendwie nicht gut skaliert pcwelt muss ich sagen, aber wer denkt sich
bei intel immer diese sachen aus und dann kürzen sie das wahrscheinlich ab noch mit
tvb oder sowas, der kann, sofern die cpu unter 70 grad celsius läuft, noch einmal 100 megahertz
obendrauf packen, deswegen sieht man hier schon mal, die 5,3 gigahertz werden wir im test nicht
immer zu aufheben bekommen, die 4,9 gigahertz wiederum hängen sehr stark von der tdp ab,
die standardmäßige tdp der cpu beläuft sich auf 125 watt, dieser wert wird im bios auch
als pl1 bzw power limit 1 bezeichnet, so viel watt kann sich die cpu wirklich dauerhaft
auch im stress des über mehrere stunden aufnehmen, dann gibt es aber noch einen zweiten wert,
das sogenannte pl2, der liegt bei 250 watt und bei einem tauwert von 66 sekunden übersetzt
bedeutet das, und das hier ist übelst der benchmark cheat, das hier ist eigentlich so
eine sauerei, wenn man sich das mal genau überlegt, aber juckt kein, der zeigt es auch
gleich noch, also wenn man sich das überlegt, die haben quasi ein normales power limit von
125 watt, das ist so relativ normal, und jetzt haben sie ein zweites power limit eingeführt
250 watt, das darf für 56 sekunden erreicht werden, das heißt solang ein benchmark läuft,
die meisten benchmarks sind ja relativ schnell durch, heißt das der benchmark läuft hiermit,
wohingegen normale anwendungen hiermit laufen, das ist eigentlich beschiss, also ich glaube
nicht, dass es rechtlich gesehen beschiss ist, aber irgendwo ist es doch beschiss, wenn
man sich überlegt, dass ein benchmark halt einfach besser ist, als das was am ende benutzbar
ist, so ein bisschen beschiss ist es, beschiss light, bei vorauslasten über 56 sekunden
bis zu 250 watt aufnehmen, das wirkt sich dann eben aber auch sehr sehr stark auf die
cpu benchmarks aus, es ist meiner meiner schon leicht ironisch und ich ziehe mich sich auch
nicht ganz zufällig, dass so typische benchmarks wie jetzt Cinebench R15 oder auch der integrierte
prozessortest in 3d mark, ziemlich genau in der Mitte läuft, das hat nämlich eins zur
folge, wenn ich jetzt Cinebench R20 multi core run ausführe, kriegt die cpu beim ersten
testdurchlauf ungefähr 6000, 6000, ja guck jetzt erklärt das, jetzt erklärt das, das
ist wirklich, das ist das ist gecheated, weil eben der boost von 250 watt noch aktiv ist
und dadurch die cpu auf allen kern auf 4,9 gigahertz taktet, wenn ich jetzt aber direkt
im anschluss den cinebench run noch einmal durchführe, also ohne eine pause zu haben,
dann taktet die cpu nur noch mit 4,2 bis 4,3 gigahertz, weil eben die ddp auf 125 watt
ist, das ist gecheated im endeffekt oder am strech, das ist wirklich ein krasser unterschied,
aus dem grund, das ist gecheated im endeffekt, zu geil, also ich habe selber quasi im bios
eingestellt 125 watt pl1, 250 watt pl2 und 56 seconden tau, tatsächlich gibt es nämlich
auch noch bei den mainboards unterschiede, für die comic lag s prozessoren braucht ihr
übrigens zwingend ein neues mainboard mit dem socket, warum intel, warum, warum ein neues
mainboard, also eure cpu hat sich seit fünf jahren nichts geändert, so grundlegend, warum
braucht man mal wieder einen neuen socket, mal wieder ein neues mainboard, also langsam
wird das bei intel wirklich lächerlich, oder was sagt ihr, also langsam langsam übertreiben
sie es, zumal die die plattform an sich auch total abstinkt gegen amd, die haben kein neues
pc express, die haben nicht viele usb anschlüsse, die haben genug genug im endeffekt, haben
nicht so viele pci lanes an sich, das stinkt total ab, 1200, der aus meiner sicht eigentlich
komplett überflüssig ist, er bringt nämlich absolut keine neuerung im vergleich zum vorgänger,
ich habe die gleiche anzahl pci express lanes, pci express 3.0, kein pci express 4.0, auch
die usb anschluss anzahl ist gleich, wir gucken mal gleich was die mainboards kosten, das gucken
wir gerade mal, was kosten denn die mainboards, ich mein intel ist unsinnig teuer bei solchen
sachen, halt wenn man sich wirklich für jeden kacke neues mainboard kaufen muss, wie ist
das ding z, nee was, z390 und den z390 waren die alten oder, was brauchen wir jetzt, z490
hier, ok z490 anscheinend, ist halt total hängen geblieben, gucken wir mal was, z490 was kosten
so die mainboards, bestimmt wieder ein schnapper, achja, guck mal da, 1000 euro mainboard, excellent,
das bramer, ja, es scheint zumindest mainboards zu geben, die so in preisregionen liegen wo
man sagen könnte, ja das geht in ordnung, aber die meisten mainboards kosten deutlich
über 200 euro, was nicht ohne ist, das aqua ist wassergekühlt, ja deswegen heißt der auch
aqua, das ist nur für besonders hotte grills, es sieht aber optisch echt schick aus, srock,
so was kostet das mainboard was er hier hat, er hat hier den extreme, in extreme irgendwie
asus extreme, so was hat er wahrscheinlich hier, was zum, zurück zu den mainboards, ihr
seht jetzt hier links, zurück zu den mainboards, ich will das bild von den mainboards sehen,
was hat der z490, pc welt wenn die auflösung besser wäre, dann würde ich aber was erkennen,
z490, hier, arus, das ist gigabyte, ar, nee, wie schreibt man den kram, aurus, extreme,
die namen für die mainboards, 408, du scheiße, warum ist das so teuer, 794, sind die irgendwie
geistig umnachtet, ok, schauen wir mal weiter, schauen wir mal andere, wir gucken mal andere
sachen, intel sockel 1200, intel ist wirklich was das angeht unter aller sau, was ist das
billigste, das billigste z490 mainboard, was ist das billigste, hier, 139, haben wir denn
was mit 10 gigabit, haben wir denn was mit 10 gigabit vielleicht, bin ich mal gespannt,
mal gucken, 500, seid ihr denn total hängen geblieben, da kann ich mir einfach eine 40
euro netzwerkarte von ebay kaufen, seid ihr denn total bescheuert oder was, ok, die dinger
sind teuer, die mainboards, die sind ordentlich, die sind ordentlich, die sind ordentlich
teuer, die haben immer noch kein pc express 4, nö, intel hat ja wahrscheinlich auch gar
keine cpu, die pc express 4 kann, weil intel ja eigentlich eine cpu architektur hat von
vor 5 jahren, ok, schauen wir mal weiter, ops, ich muss die musik ausmachen, ops, hainsaw,
ja, es ist so hängen geblieben von intel, ne, so hängen geblieben, wir machen einfach
die gleiche cpu, die gleichen mainboards, aber wir machen einen neuen sockel, was ist
mit intel los, ich mein intel könnte ja wenigstens jetzt mal den leuten ein bisschen entgegen
kommen und sagen ok, wir haben eine neue cpu, die schon teuer genug ist, aber ihr könnt
euer altes mainboard dafür verwenden, aber nope, gibt's nicht, zahnzahl ist gleich,
auch hier hat es sicher eine geschwindigkeit, sich werdet auch genauso beim sata anschlüssen,
habt ihr exakt das gleiche wie bei z390, zurück zu den mainboards, ihr seht jetzt hier links
mal die werte, die ich ermittelt hab, mit einem asus auregi maximus 12 extreme mit den
intel spezifikationen, also hier hab ich wie gesagt intel spezifikationen manuell im bios
eingestellt, jetzt blenden wir rechts daneben mal die werte ein, die ihr mit dem gleichen
asus mainboard erhaltet, wenn ihr euch quasi an die hersteller spezifikationen haltet, also
quasi die cpu so betreibt, wie das bios eingestellt ist, wenn ihr es so von asus kauft, ihr seht
jetzt, dass die werte, dass sie ähnlich sind, also abgesehen von ein paar mess toleranzen,
ich seh da keinen unterschied, nicht wirklich, das bedeutet übersetzt, dass asus sich an
intel spezifikationen hält, jetzt hab ich aber noch ein zweites mainboard hier und zwar
200 gigabyte und jetzt blende ich euch mal die werte an, die ich mit diesem board erzählt
habe, jetzt seht ihr hier schon einen langzeit test, also allen tests, die länger als eine
müte dauern, da ist jetzt zum beispiel ein blender oder bei handbrake die benötigte zeit
für den test deutlich geringer ist, das liegt daran, dass gigabyte sich eben hier nicht
an intel spezifikationen gehalten hat, sondern die cpu dauerhaft quasi beliebig viel bzw.
maximal 250 watt aufnehmen kann, das führt eben dazu, dass die cpu dauerhaft den 4,9
gigabyte boostet, das finde ich nicht gut, das sollte nicht die fault sein, das sollte
nicht die fault sein, dass es diese allcore turbo option gibt, ist ok, ist auch richtig
so, aber defaultmäßig sollte man es nicht machen, man kann eben quasi deutlich bessere
ergebnisse erzielt, wenn der test länger als 46 sekunden dauert, jetzt ist natürlich erstmal
ein bisschen problematisch, weil je nachdem zu welchem mainboard ihr greift, ihr kriegt
jetzt schon mal eine unterschiedliche leistung, was sich dann eben auf die anwendungen auswirkt,
jetzt ist aber noch die frage, wirkt sich das nur auf die anwendungen aus oder eventuell
auf die spiele und wie beurteilt man dann quasi die leistung, captain pang fragt ob
das nicht auch auf lange zeit die cpu können, ne, das ist genauso wie leute sagen, da kann
es nicht so viel vcore geben beim übertakten und hier und sonst was, wenn es die cpu aushält,
dann überlebt es in der regel auch, also jetzt mal, wie hat der kaboom früher gesagt,
hand aufs herz, jetzt ehrlich mal, ist wirklich schon jemals eine cpu abgeraucht, also bei
mir, wenn ich jetzt überlege, seit 5 und seit 20 jahren, wo ich desktop computer am
start hab, mir ist noch nie, noch nie, egal wie sehr ich übertaktet habe oder was ich
für dinge gemacht hab, mir ist noch nie eine cpu kaputtgegangen, noch nie, alles andere
ist mir schon kaputtgegangen, aber eine cpu hab ich glaub ich noch nie geschafft zu schrotten,
sogar meine usv ist mir kaputtgegangen, alles schon gefühlt irgendwie, aber cpu ist noch
nie, also ich hab jetzt strikt darauf geachtet, dass ich mich immerhin übertaktet, hast du
dein jetzing 8700k übertaktet, ja, aber gerade nicht, gerade nicht, gerade hab ich nur allcore
turbo an auf 4,6ghz glaub ich oder 4,7 oder sowas, aber ich bin blöd, ich hab nämlich,
also ich muss nämlich dazu erzählen, also ich hab meine cpu übertaktet und letztens
ist mein rechner abgekackt und da bin ich einfach ins bios rein und hab ab dieses übertakt
mal rausgemacht um zu gucken ob es daran lag, wahrscheinlich lags gar nicht daran und was
richtig low brain von mir ist, ich kanns euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil ich ja nicht ins
bios kann, was richtig low brain von mir ist, ich hab die übertaktung rausgenommen, aber
ich hab die spannung oben gelassen, also sprich, meine cpu hat jetzt nicht mehr leistung bis
auf den allcore turbo, aber mehr spannung, was irgendwie total hängen geblieben ist,
wenn man sichs mal so überlegt, ne, aber was auch immer, aber weiter, John hat ne dvd ich
glaub 105, bei 105 grad tacken die sich runter, ich glaub 105 grad ist es bei meiner, ich
kanns euch zeigen, erinnert mich mal, ich zeig es euch, wir machen die intel overclock tools
auf, ich zeig es euch, intel, was ist mit euch los, ich mein, warum kostet das ding
100 euro mehr, was rechtfertigt das 100 euro mehr zu kosten, vor allem das board kostet
auch ordentlich asche, allerdings sind die amd boards auch nicht ohne, muss man sagen,
ne, ich mein, guck mal, der 3900x hat zwei kerne mehr, das ist schonmal ordentlich was,
das bringt, wenn du multicore anwendung hast, bringt das ordentlich performance mit zwei
kerne, das ist halt einfach zwei kerne, was soll ich dazu großartig sagen, so, da sind
also da schon irgendwie 50 prozent leistung auf einschlag, wenn das ordentlich multicore
ist, so, die taktraten sind ungefähr gleich, wobei man sagen muss, dass amd bei einigen
sachen bisschen effizienter als intel ist, deswegen ist gar nicht so schlimm, dass die
niedrigeren takt haben, allerdings in single core und in, ja, wo amd jetzt den hohen core
count nicht ausspielen kann, ist intel immer noch ein ticken schneller, ein bisschen, ein
bisschen, ja, und gerade in spielen ist es dann halt so, dass intel immer noch ein bisschen
weiter vorne ist, so, ähm, äh, ja, so, also, aber warum ist der preis da jetzt 100, 150
euro mehr, das verstehe ich nicht, also wie gesagt amd ist ein 12 kerner, aber aktuell
nach straßenpreisen schon viel 429 euro erhältlich, der 9900k dagegen ist so bei 526 euro, ungefähr
für den preis dürfte der 10900k auch erhältlich sein, die uvp von intel liegt nämlich bei
499 us dollar, dürfte umgerecht eben ungefähr 529 euro sein, allerdings listen erste händer
die cpu erst da 589 euro, was aus meiner sicht definitiv viel zu teuer ist, ja, viel zu teuer,
aber die händler machen das gerne, die, wenn neue intel cpus rauskommen, weil intel ja
irgendwie nicht in der lage ist, ordentlich cpus zu liefern beim launch, gut amd auch
nicht, es gab mal ne zeit, da wurde ein produkt gelaunched und es war verfügbar, das ist heute
aber nicht mehr so, heute wird ein produkt gelaunched und es gibt 200 samples für influencer
und drei monate später kann sich das dann alles kaufen, kann sich, so können sich das
dann alle kaufen, ok, das müssen wir uns jetzt mal in ruhe angucken, also, unterschied zwischen
altem intel topmodell und neuem intel topmodell, blender ist ein bisschen schneller, handbrake
ist ein bisschen schneller, scenebench ist ein bisschen schneller, warum der so viel schneller
ist im scenebench multicore, ja gut, ich weiß jetzt nicht wie er die tests durchgeführt
hat, das hier ist der, das hier ist der, gerade beim scenebench, das ist der intel cheat mit
den 250 watt, wenn er das so gemacht hat, wieso, wie war das mit den kern cpu vergleicht,
ah, der hat zwei kerne mehr, dann ist klar, dann ist klar, dann ist klar, dann hat er
zwei kerne mehr und den intel cheat am start, also zwei kerne plus intel cheat ist ja kein
wunder, dass der hier mal, was ist das, 15 prozent schneller ist, und was besonders geil
ist, wenn man sich das hier anguckt, dass für 100 euro weniger der ryzen einen kern
mehr hat und dementsprechend gleich das ding komplett aus dem, was ist das hier, wegschiebt,
wegbläst, irgendwie, so, single core ist klar, single core ist aktuelle ryzen generation,
meistens ein bisschen, minimal, ein tick hinter intel noch, aber hier oben alles was multicore
ist haut der ryzen intel weg, aus den socken haut er die, genau, das ist die richtige,
das ist die richtige formulierung, excellent chat, wo ich ja drauf warte ist, dass das
amd einen refresh rausbringt vom ryzen, oder vom aktuellen ryzen, oder ryzen 4, 5, was
auch immer, der dann noch mal die messlatte ein bisschen höher hängt, also sprich, wenn
es amd schafft, irgendwie noch mal das ding, 10 prozent reichen ja schon, wenn amd 9 cpus
rausbringt, wo die einfach nur noch mal 10 prozent obendrauf legen, intel kann ja nix
machen aktuell, was sollen die machen, guck mal, die haben die letzten 3 cpus, die sie
rausgebracht haben, was waren das jetzt, 9.900k, 8.900k, ne 8.700k, ach intel cpu und 10.900k,
da hat sich nichts getan dazwischen, hat sich nichts getan, und wenn amd jetzt noch mal
10 prozent drauf haut, dann sind sie auch single core performance mäßig vorne, und
intel hat komplett, aber wirklich absolut komplett abgeschissen.
Ich hatte die letzten, ich will es jetzt immer nicht übertreiben, aber die letzten 10 jahre
vorne weg, wenn es nicht sogar die letzten 15 jahre waren, nur intel systeme, weil amd
nix hatte, aber aktuell muss man sagen, intel wird abkacken, wenn das so weiter geht.
10.900k nur in den single core anwendungen vorsprung hat, in sämtlichen multi core anwendungen
wird er teilweise sogar echt deutlich geschlagen, was eigentlich ein bisschen verwunderlich
ist, weil man hat, wenn man überlegt, dass er 10 mal 4,9 gigahertz hat, im vergleich
zu 12 mal 4,0, aber amd hat hier eben auch eine bisschen bessere ipc, ja patrick sehe
ich auch so, wäre richtig pock, der im schnitt hier auch ungefähr bei 12 prozent liegt,
das war jetzt eben die anwendungsleistung, für viele ist noch deutlich interessanter,
also schafft der 10.900k wirklich den 9.900k als beste spieler cpu, ja muss er ja, muss
er ja, er hat ein paar megahertz mehr takt, aber das wars, kurz gesagt, ja, aber wirklich
nur sehr marginal, also wenn wir jetzt auf die werte schauen, die blenden hier immer
die fps-werte ein, zuerst einmal in full hd, dann sehen wir, dass der 10.900k den 9.900k
im schnitt nur um 2,4 prozent schlagen kann, guck mal, und das vor allem auf cpu-lastige
wendungen zurückzuführen, ist hier z.b. civilization 6, und dafür soll, dafür soll
ich mir eine neue cpu und ein neues mainboard kaufen, dafür soll ich 1000 euro ausgeben,
oder mehr, dafür soll ich 1000 euro ausgeben, für 1 fps, für 1 fps, easy, oh sorry, ok
10 fps, ja, ist ok, 13, 13 fps, aber ansonsten, ist wirklich, ist es nicht viel, bist du von
irgend wem gesponsort, ne, bin ich nicht, zumindest nicht auf twitch, und auf youtube
hab ich auch nix mehr laufen, weil ich mach ja auf youtube grad nix mehr, die grafik,
disclaimer, stimmt so nicht, stimmt so nicht, die grafikkarte, die ich aktuelle verwende,
die 1080ti, die hab ich noch tatsächlich von ein video gekriegt, ah, nicht, dass jetzt
hier irgendwie die abmahnung direkt raus ist, nein, hab ich nicht versucht mit ecc, ich
mein, wenn man jetzt nochmal auf die taktraten zurück geht, dann schafft der 10900k eben
auf allen seelen kern 4,9 gigahertz, das liegt schlichtweg daran, dass in spielen die auslastung
einfach nicht im maximum ist, also das bei spielen ungefähr 20, 30%, im schlimmsten
fall vielleicht 40% auslastung bei dieser cpu, das heißt man kommt auch nicht in dieses
tdp limit rein, weil die cpu einfach im schnitten ungefähr 100 watt benötigt, in den spitzen
bleibt auch mal 130 watt, aber dadurch wird eben dieser tau wert, der nach 56 sekunden
greift nicht aus, der tau wert, das hört sich an, als macht der bauer grad wieder stickstoff
kühlung, wo ist der tau wert, vergleich dazu, 9900k auf allen 8 kern 4,7 gigahertz, die
auch konstant halten kann, das ist ja mehr 200 megahertz mehr, die eben in full hd zu
gerade einmal 2,4% mehr, 2,4% mehr leistung, 2,4% mehr leistung, 2,4%, was anderes fällt
mir dazu nicht ein, und dafür ein neues mainboard und eine neue cpu, dafür kann man doch schon
mal 1000 euro ausgeben, oder, hatte irgendwo die cinebench ergebnisse drin stehen, leute
wir machen das, wir machen das, wisst ihr was wir nach dem video machen, wir machen
einen cinebench auf 8700k, der aktuell wohlgemerkt nicht übertaktiv ist, nur allcore turbo,
und wir gucken mal wie schnell der ist im vergleich zu dem, aber single core, single core, machen
wir single core, dass ich multi core nicht mithalten kann ist klar, ich hab nur halb
so viele cpu kerne, wir machen single core, wir gucken mal wie viel wirklich schneller
geworden ist die cpu in den letzten jahren, 5 jahre alte cpu, naja nicht ganz, 3 jahre
alte cpu, mit neuer cpu, das probieren wir mal aus, ich installiere mal gleich cinebench
und dann machen wir mal einen single core, gucken wir mal an, oder tanser geht wieder
abwürfen mit abos auf sich, excellent, wer kriegt denn jetzt welche, jaste999, cheat
995, ja der ist schon lange am start, der hat auch wirklich mal nen sub verdient hier,
und spatze granate, dankeschön tanser, das geht aber hier wieder richtig ab, nice, und
jetzt hört auf, fangt nicht wieder so an leute, fangt nicht wieder so an, ich sags euch, behaltet
euer geld, und jetzt verschenkt der patrick gleich 5 neue abos, dankeschön für die ganzen
gifts hier, sub gifts, wer kriegt denn was ab, müller joe, niklas88, by the way fällt
mir ein unser spezial azubi, der hieß glaub ich niklas, unser c lattenzaun azubi, der
nicht wusste, dass c sharp c sharp heißt, sondern gemeint hat, das heißt c lattenzaun,
glaub der hieß niklas, ka sa len, eins kriegt eins, und jonas was, dont read the rest, excellent,
IQ des chats geht durch die decke, das heißt nicht c raute, das heißt c lattenzaun wenn
schon, aber jetzt ist gut leute, nicht wieder übertreiben, oh nein, es geht wieder los,
leute ernsthaft, macht langsam, macht langsam, noch mal 3 neue abos vom tazer, wasserpatrick,
tommykart9991, ja der ist auch lange da, der hat es auf jeden fall auch verdient, und realverse
player eu, poggers, das passt, dann haben wir den schlechtesten spieler eu und den schlechtesten
streamer eu jetzt hier zusammen, perfekt, excellent, es bringt übrigens gar nix abos
zu schenken, weil ich hab gar keine sub emotes, ich wollte heute morgen, heute morgen war ich
kurz davor auf twitter zu gehen und zu posten, 50 euro pro emote, wer macht, da melden sich
bestimmt ein paar, jetzt wo ich so viele subs gekriegt hab, kann ich aber die kohle ausgeben,
ja so der große unterschied ist das nicht, erinnert mich dran, wir wollten nach dem video,
wollten uns die ne bench bei mir machen, single core, und ich wollte euch das inter über
taktungstool zeigen, auf was ich meine cpu gerade eingestellt hab, und dann gucken wir
mal, was eine 3 jahre alte cpu zu sagen hat gegen eine aktuelle cpu, dass sich bei internet
nix tut.
Überhaupt diese werte zu erreichen, und ich muss echt sagen, was die stromaufnahme in
spielen betrifft, war ich absolut geschockt, also das nur mal kurz vergleichswerte, 9900k
hat in spielen im schnitt ungefähr 60 watt, beim 10900k waren es, stimmt, und wir brauchen
noch sub badges, und wir brauchen noch sub badges, tatsächlich sub badges brauchen wir
ja auch noch, knapp über 100 watt, das sind 40 watt mehr, für gerade einmal 2,5 prozent
mehr leistung.
Also ich bin ganz ehrlich, es wäre möglich, dass ich ein sehr schlechtes cpu sample erwischt
habe, weil ich einfach das erstellt habe, dass die spannung und damit angehend auch
die leistungsaufnahme bei 4,9 ghz schon wirklich extrem hoch lag, was dann auch dazu resultiert
hat, dass die wärmentwicklung wirklich sehr hoch war, also bei spielen ist ein luftkühler
a la bquai darkrock pro 4 tatsächlich noch ausreichend, ich hab absichtlich luftkühler
getestet, in spielen sind wir ungefähr bei 65 grad, unter voll last, zum beispiel cinebench
a15 sind wir schon bei 83 grad, das ist doch auch vollkommen ok, 83 grad, exzellent, hat
meine cpu auch, weil ich die spanung erhöht hab, aus absolut unsinnigen gründen, ich
hab sie am anfang des streams gerade erzählt, nur für die leute, die jetzt dabei gekommen
sind, mir ist gerade aufgefallen, dass ich letztens meine cpu wieder auf normalen takt
gesetzt hab, allerdings die spanung im bios immer noch eingestellt hab, also sprich ich
hab jetzt glaub irgendwie 0,18, was ist das, amper, nee volt, mehr, spanung, obwohl ich
sie nicht brauche, total bescheuert.
also hier sieht man schon, es wird nicht mehr allzu viel über takt und spielraum möglich
sein, als definitiv nicht mit luftkühler, selbst mit wasserkühlung wirds schon kritisch,
dazu komm ich jetzt dann auch gleich noch, wasserkühlung, wer braucht schon wasserkühlung?
boah, what the fuck, ernsthaft intel, 217 watt leistungsaufnahme, da schmilzt ja das mainboard
als
Auf allen 12K mit 4Ghz taktet haben wir maximal eine Leistungsaufnahme von etwa 145 Watt im Schnitt sogar nur 135
und trotzdem schafft es der 3900X eine höhere Anwendungsleistung zu erbringen
eben auch dank seiner zusätzlichen Kette
Ja, der ist auch ganz klar, der hat zwei Kerne mehr
Die Leistungsaufnahme zur Leistung ist, beim 10900K meint man wirklich, alles andere ist gut
Jetzt kommen wir eben zurück zur Übertaktung, das habe ich vor allem deswegen durchgeführt
weil Intel die Comet Lake S Prozessoren damit bepriesen hat, dass sie sich sehr gut übertakten lassen
und es ist ja auch im Vorhinein auf Twitter ein Leak aufgetaucht, dass ein Tester es geschafft hat
seinen Engineering Sample, also seine Aussage nach problemlos auf 5,4Ghz mit herkömmlichen
5,4Ghz?
Das wäre aber ganz schön extremst viel
...könnlichen Kühlmethoden, also das heißt entweder eine Wasserkühlung oder eine Luftkühlung zu betreiben
kann ich jetzt mit meinem Test Sample absolut nicht bestätigen, also wirklich in keinster Weise
Ich habe wirklich relativ viel Zeit dafür investiert, zu übertakten, habe dafür auch extra auf eine All-in-One-Wasser-Kühlung gesetzt
von NZXT mit 280mm großen Radiator
Bestimmt gesponsert, bestimmt gesponsert
Das absolute Maximum, was ich auf der Dauerlast erreicht habe, waren 5,1Ghz auf allen Kernen
Das ist meine Meinung schon wirklich sehr mager
Fühlt dann tatsächlich auch dazu, dass es in Single Core, weil eben die 5,3Ghz Boost nicht mehr reicht
während die Leistung sogar niedriger ausfällt, also ohne Übertaktung
und in Multi-Core Anwendungen, der Leistungszuwachs nur ungefähr bei 7-9% über dem Unlocked-Bio-Slick
Das ist aber nicht viel, guck mal, das Übertakten bringt ja kaum was
...dass es dauerhaft 4,9Ghz halten kann
ist schon sehr wenig, vor allem, wenn man die Leistungsaufnahme, die da dahinter steckt, begutachten
Wir haben nämlich einen Leistungspick von 277 Watt und eine durchschnittliche Leistungsaufnahme von 250 Watt
...hohohoh, okay, jetzt wird es aber langsam ein bisschen viel, Intel
jetzt wird es aber echt ein bisschen viel
277 Watt Leistung, okay, das ist ordentlich
das ist wirklich nur für die ganz Hottengrills, ja
Zurückgedacht im Unlocked-Bio, also 4,9Ghz auf allen Kern, waren wir im Schnitt bei 170 Watt
Das sind 80 watt mehr leistungsaufnahme im schnitt für gerade einmal sieben bis neun prozent mehr leistung also knapp 50 prozent
höhere leistungsaufnahme für sieben bis neun prozent mehr leistung
das ist vom verhältnis her wirklich unterirdisch
das ist scheiße
die spieleleistung zu betrachten
die haben wir durch die 200 mega mehr auf einen fern
gerade einmal eine 1,2 prozent höhere spieleleistung
1,2 prozent höhere spieleleistung
1,2 prozent höhere leistungsaufnahme
interna das lohnt sich aber richtig
zumindest mit dem test sample was ich hier habe
wie gesagt ist es sehr gut möglich dass ich
bei der silicon loterie
realverse player eu fragt
empfehlung für budget laptop
so um 300 euro vielleicht
noch 400 euro linux drauf zu klatschen
also wenn es ein laptop sein muss
die linovo syncpaddinger funktionieren
unter linux ziemlich gut aber eine
richtige empfehlung habe ich nicht weil ich habe kein notebook
kein aktuelles
wirklich pech hatte ein extrem schlechtes
sample erwischt habe aber nach den messwerten
die ich raus bekommen habe kann ich einfach nur sagen
übertaktung selbst mit einer guten
mannwasserkühlung absolut nicht empfehlenswert
der idle rise schon neuen
die lagen nämlich unter vollauslastung
bei satten 93 grad Celsius
und das ist meiner mein nach
auf dauer eigentlich schon fast soviel
besonders wenn man eben betrachtet dass ich über 1,4
volt anlegen musste um diese
5,1 gigahertz überhaupt halten zu können
also ich muss sagen ich hätte von der 10 generation
deutlich mehr erwartet
vor allem generation
in anführungenstrichen bei intel
das ist ja seit fünf jahren das gleiche
900k die schnellste
gaming cpu angekündigt das hat sich
in unseren testen auch bestätigt allerdings
wie gesagt nur mit sehr marginalem
vorsprung im vergleich zum 9900k bei
deutlich gesteigerte leistungsaufnahme
wenn man es jetzt aktuell zu md-produkten vergleicht
sie haben deutlich energie für die
sie haben die deutlich bessere leistung
multifedding anwendung
am martze 2090 fragt was hast du eigentlich
für einen mobilanbieter aldi talk habe ich
nur in spielen in einer geringen
auflösung noch einen wirklichen
wirklichen vorsprung sobald man die auflösung
auf qhd hoch stellt oder sogar auf uhd
schmilzt diese vorsprung immer weiter
weil die grafikkarte limitiert und
deswegen kann ich einfach nur sagen
der 10900k lohnt sich aus meiner sicht
wirklich nur für high fps gamer die einfach
egal in welchem spiel immer die maximale
leistung haben aber selbst dann ist das
preisleistungsmäßig voll für ein arsch
jetzt hinsichtlich das sehr teuren
mainboard ist ja dafür benötigt und auch eben
bis des cpu preises meiner meiner hat
intel den jahrelangen
vorsprung den sie eben in der fertigung hatten
ja mittlerweile vollständig
da hat er recht ich muss sogar sagen das amd
durch das 7nm verfahren ja die
führung übernommen hat ist einfach so
kann man nicht alles sagen und ich muss echt sagen
intel sollte alles dransetzen
um die 10nm fertigung oder sogar besser noch
die 7nm fertigung schleunigst
auf die reize bekommen das kriegen sie nicht gebacken
das kriegen sie leblich gebacken
vor kurzem sind gerüchte
aufgekommen dass bei
10.3 nochmal eine abc steigung von
20 prozent stattfinden soll zusätzlich
immer noch also wenn das stimmt
wenn das stimmt das
amd mit dem
nächsten ryzen refresh 20 prozent
drauflegt ist vorbei dann
ist wirklich intel wirklich die
hauts komplett intel aus den
socken pc lustig
doch das handy von der arbeit was
ich bekomme hat telekom gedulds
takt und wenn es wirklich
so eintritt dann gehe ich stark
davon aus dass auch der einzige forschung den
intel aktuell noch hat und zwar in den spielen
spätestens dann obsolet sein wird wie gesagt
ich kann nur sagen ich bin mehr als enttäuscht
was haltet ihr denn? also
2 fps 1000 euro
für 2 fps
ist wirklich
ok also wir wollten jetzt ja ausbrennen
was was krieg ich in meinem
cinebench
aus dem microsoft
store
warum sollte ich das aus dem
microsoft store laden?
ergibt doch überhaupt keinen sinn warum sollte ich das machen?
Microsoft store
woodface aber richtig
äh welchen
cinebench hat er denn verwendet? stimmt ich
wollte es doch jetzt mit meiner cpu vergleichen
moment ich wollte es doch mit meiner cpu vergleichen
was hatte er denn was hat er denn verwendet
hier?
r20? hier
ok jetzt
probieren wir mal aus 3 jahre alte cpu
gegen neue cpu
cinebench
kann man das nicht einfach so
runterladen?
wie?
das gibt es nur im store? ah hier
direkter download excellent
cinebench r20
windows
so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
also man muss dazu sagen
ich bin am stream
und ich kompiliere nebenbei chrome
mit 4 cpu kern
aber wir machen ja nur
einen single core test
also schauen wir mal ja
entpacken
extract
also schauen wir mal ja
es ist nicht so ganz repräsentativ
weil
ja weil rechner ist halt ausgelastet
wir können die vm ja wir können kurz
pause machen in der vm wir machen kurz pause
in der vm wir können an der stelle weitermachen
gleich
so
jetzt pause bei der vm
jetzt muss er erstmal 16g
ram wieder auf die platte schreiben
oh das scheint aber anstrengend zu sein 16gb
auf die ssd zu schreiben ja
ja es ist aber auf ssd
es macht eigentlich gar keinen ton
ich hab das grad verdrängt im kopf
dass ssd's keinen ton machen
es gibt auch so ein paar sachen
die vermisse ich ja nur wirklich nicht ne
so ein paar sachen vermisse ich echt nicht
von früher zum beispiel das festplatten
klicken und sowas
bevor wir den starten
wow intel
extreme
tuning utility brauchen wir jetzt
also
meine cpu ist aktuell
auf
lull
wo sieht man das
ist das zum information
ah hier
ok man sieht
dass man nicht sieht man muss erstmal
ein bisschen last drauf machen
ok accept
den da
wo kann ich den auf single core umstellen
ich hab ewig keinen cinebench mehr verwendet
ah hier
so ne
oder hab ich das jetzt richtig gemacht
leute
ich denk mal schon
so
kann man sonst
ah man kann aber
das wohl auch raus machen
und kann sagen
advanced benchmark
und dann sagt man single core aha
so geht das
run
also man sieht hier
er geht hoch auf 4,5
ah das ist bestimmt avx oder
benutzt er avx das cinebench
cinebench
also wir sind auf temperatur
3,5
ah was auch immer
avx
ja dann ist klar dass er nur 4,5 geht
ist doch irgendwie so
ich hab glaub ich den offset
ich hab den offset eingestellt
für avx 200mhz
dass er nicht
das ist auch noch aus der zeit wo ich
übertaktet hab den offset kann ich eigentlich
rausnehmen ist total bescheuert
ich hab überhaupt keinen sinn mehr dass ich den noch drin hab
auf cinebench
wie spricht man das eigentlich aus
cinebench, sinebench
cinebench
jitbench
so wie router
kinebench wäre auch noch was
oh ja
ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass es tatsächlich
cinebench heißt so wie cinema genau
aber
kinebench finde
ich auch gut
so wie china
das wo es
tatsächlich leute gibt die das sagen
in hessen
sind wir da eher bei china
sinebench
oder was der franzose dann sagt
sinebench oder so
was haltet ihr eigentlich von einem emote
wo wir einen poggers machen
mit franzosen schnurrbart
oder so
das muss dann poggers heißen
poggers
wahrscheinlich erkennt man das aber nicht
und
der kriegt auch noch so eine franzosenmütze auf
und vielleicht kriegt er
auch noch ein baguette in die hand oder so
um alle klischees zu bedienen
dann haben wir echt alles
wenn wir poggers
mit schnurrbart
der franzosenmütze und ein baguette
dann haben wir alle klischees bedient
du darfst nicht so viel sprechen
sonst slowt der benchmark down
echt warum sollte das denn machen
das ist ein single core
hab ich das bisschen task geswitcht
da von windows das
das werden wir schon aushalten
mal ganz davon abgesehen
wenn das sprechenden problem ist
ich streame im hintergrund auf dem gleichen rechner
und hab nebenbei
okay die haben wir jetzt ausgemacht
die vm haben wir aus
wie lang läuft denn das so in der regel
bis das build voll ist
na gut
dann wird das noch ein bisschen
da dauert das jetzt eine ganze weile
geht das
ich hab ewig kein single bench laufen lassen
geht das bis das build voll ist
die mode vorschläge
sehr gut
naja aber es spricht doch nichts dagegen
das im hintergrund laufen zu lassen
ich mein single core
who cares single core
das sollte schon im hintergrund
single coren
ja also wunderbar
dann probieren wir das mal aus
ja und was ich euch noch zeigen wollte genau
also ich hab mal vx offset
von 200mhz
was total bescheuert ist
das ist alles noch von meinem
übertaktungs setting
ich bin richtig hängen geblieben eigentlich
ich müsste eigentlich mal wieder übertakken
also ich hatte den ja sonst laufen
auf 5,1
ich hatte ihn maximal auf
5,1 konnte ich ihn laufen lassen
allerdings
wurde er da schon sehr warm
der ist auch
ich glaub der ist unter prime 95 auch ans limit
dann gekommen
mit 5,1 dann hab ich ihn permanent
auf 5 gigahertz
mit 200mhz
auf avx offset
ja
das heißt selbst jetzt
ist der cinebench rip richtig beknackt
wie gesagt ich hab den avx offset
gespricht das ist 200mhz langsamer
als er eigentlich wäre
aber nichtsdestotrotz gucken wir mal was ein single core
benchmark gerade so bringt
im vergleich zu einer 3 jahre alten cpu
und
dass die 5 gigahertz überhaupt
möglich waren ging halt auch nur weil
ich den damals geköpft
hab mit heatsprinter ab und flüssig
metall dazwischen
tja
was gibt es denn was gibt es sonst noch was schönes
also sagst du
china ne ich sag china so richtig
china
gibt es eigentlich
gibt es eigentlich irgendwelche
neuen linux distributionen oder
sachen die man sich mal angucken müsste
also manche seiten sehen mit dark mode
wirklich nicht gut aus
mx linux warum ist
mx linux eigentlich so
so beliebt wir haben das ausprobiert ich fand das mega scheiße fand das total mies weiß
gar nicht warum das so beliebt ist manjaro beste excellent manjaro ist hier big big brain
distribution die seite sieht halt aus wie von 1995 das hatte ich früher mal als firewall
laufen bei mir vor irgendwie 15 jahren oder so zu den zeiten als ich noch nilux firewall selbst
benutzt habe weil ich mir gedacht habe man ist richtig richtig big brain wenn man das macht
danach hatte ich pf sense bzw open sense und jetzt habe ich einfach mal ein mikrotik router
ein bisschen firewall macht und fertig wozu braucht man das so was haben wir ansonsten
nichts mint mint verstehe ich dass das vorne ist das ist auch immer was ich nubs empfehle wenn
wenn wenn mich jemand fragt mit welcher linux distribution soll ich mal was soll ich mir mal
zum ausprobieren was soll ich mir nehmen da sage ich meistens neben ubuntu oder dem mint wenn du
wenn desktop mach mint drauf und gut ist da kannst du nicht allzu viel allzu viel falsch machen hast
du schon mal unter linux gezockt wenn ja wie war die performance also in letzter zeit habe
ich mich habe ich dann nicht mal viel ausprobiert weil ich mein linux halt in a vm laufen habe
und da ist mit spielen eh nix ansonsten kann man sagen denke ich durch die bank weg dass die
performance wenn es läuft nicht viel schlechter ist als unter windows allerdings die sache ist
halt wenn es läuft wenn es klitsch frei läuft und spätestens bei software mit anti cheat ist
eh vorbei was ich gerade gut ist ist was arco linux habe ich noch nie gehört arco linux linux
made easy and beautiful aha dark mode ausmachen die seite ist ein bisschen zu zu hell auf hell also
ok was ist ah das ist das ist ein arch linux mit ok warum sollte man es wäre sehr sinnvoll wenn
man auf die startseite schreibt hallo wir sind eine linux distribution auf arch basis und das
hier sind unsere vorteile so werbung machen können die ganzen projekte mich ok warum warum
soll ich das verwenden was sagen sie denn selbst warum ich das verwenden sollte nichts gibt keinen
grund zu verwenden das ist schlechte werbung das ist echt keine gute start seite arch linux mit
einfachen installer ja da kann ich auch mancharo nehmen was ist zum beispiel das wäre was eine
tabelle was unterscheidet uns zu mancharo zum beispiel ja man muss ein bisschen werbung machen
start hier nee nicht wirklich warum macht man keine start seite und schreibt hallo wir sind
linux distribution xy das und das haben wir uns auf die fahne geschrieben das sind unsere
vorteile so unterscheiden wir uns zu anderen und deswegen solltest du uns verwenden ich meine so
ein bisschen basic marketing zeug sollten die doch alle alle wenn die wollen auch dass die
leute verwenden oder was ihk prüfung wie kommt jetzt darauf ja wer hat gesagt dass er das verwendet
irgendjemand auch gesagt dass er das verwenden warum verwendest du es denn also was ist der was
ist für dich der vorteil aus sinneberg ist fertig oder ist sinneberg fertig ok wir haben 453 punkte
das heißt wir sind ungefähr ja wir haben ein bisschen zeug laufen gehabt ja so vergleichen
wir single core 535 also wenn wir mal davon ausgeht dass ich streame und nebenbei video
kucke zeug mache browser videos laufen hab zeug starte und im hintergrund auf dem zweiten
dessen um sie eine bin schlaufen habe dann sind wir 60 50 50 80 punkte unterschied und ich gehe
ganz stark von aus wenn ich mal meine bios einstellung so machen würde dass ich die af
dass ich den in a4 x offset rausmach und auch mal alles zumache und nur in single core mache
da bin ich vielleicht bei 500 und das bei der drei jahre neueren cpu also da sieht man im
endeffekt es hat sich es hat sich unterm strich eigentlich so gut wie nichts getan es hat sich
also im prinzip hat sich nichts getan bei intel was ist an a4 x offset das kann man mit den bios
einstellen dass wenn a4 x instruktion verwendet werden cpu dass er nicht seinen maximaltakt nimmt
weil a4 x instruktion die cpu besonders heiß machen a4 x sind spezielle wie nennt sich
noch mal sampler befehle sind richtig ob anweisungen also sprich anweisung an die cpu was sie machen
sollen die besonders effektiv sind in manchen bereichen und halt aber auch viel strom und
leistung ziehen und die cpu besonders warm machen zum beispiel kannst du zum beispiel gibt es
bei a4 x anweisung dass du mehrere zahlen addieren kannst anstatt immer nur zwei zum beispiel ja
genau genau teddy jub ich weiß nicht was ist alles was es da alles für instruktionen gibt aber zum
beispiel gibt es die möglichkeit dass du irgendwie zwei vector addierst also kannst du dann irgendwie
ich habe ich habe es ehrlich gesagt noch nie ausprobiert da kannst du dann anstatt einfach nur
zwei zahlen zu addieren kannst du beispielsweise mit a4 x glaube ich bis zu acht oder so zahlen
miteinander addieren was natürlich wenn man das braucht ziemlich er geschwindigkeits boost ist
so jetzt gehen wir mal von aus ich hätte man a4 x boost rausgemacht offset rausgemacht und ich
hätte sogar meine cpu 5 gigahertz übertaktet es wäre absolut kein unterschied zwischen einem
drei jahre alten neuer zwischen 3 wahrscheinlich wäre meiner sogar schneller als ein drei jahre
alte cpu drei jahre alte cpu ein bisschen übertaktet wäre wahrscheinlich schneller als
ein aktueller inter cpu und ich müsste noch mal 1000 euro für mainboard und cpu ausgeben
tja also eigentlich ziemlich fail wie ist der hotkey um in windows zwischen desktop umzuschalten
windows tasten control und feiltaste übrigens chrome kompiliert immer noch wo wir gerade dabei
sind btv das werden wir in einem der nächsten streams machen das war ein bisschen super idee
ist derjenige noch da das vorgeschlagen hat ich habe mir nämlich überlegt wenn wir streams
machen mit ideen von leuten aus dem chat kann ich ja wenigstens am anfang kurzzeitig kurz mal
erwähnen wer von wem die idee gekommen ist warum wollen die 1000 euro für ein mainboard die wollen
ich 1000 euro für mainboard die wollen 550 euro für die cpu ungefähr und ungefähr 400 euro für
das mainboard also du musst 900 bis 1000 euro ausgeben um die halt neue neue inter cpu und
inter mainboard neue inter plattform hinzustellen und du hast so gut wie kein leistungs gewinn dafür
das ist so fail aller das ist typisch intel big brain logik da kaufe ich mir lieber ohne
scheiß da kaufe ich mir lieber in 3950 x und krieg 24 kerne oder was das ding hat wieviel kerne hat
er 16 16 die nächsten anderen wahrscheinlich 24 m in 3970 x will ich mir nicht kaufen der hat
ein bisschen weniger takt glaube ich ich glaube 3950 x hatte ich hat mir damals eingeschaut war
für mich echt die beste cpu seit langem richtig viele kerne richtig viel takt also genau das
richtige für mich der ab und zu mal sachen rendert einige vms laufen hat und ordentlich spielen
will beste aber allerdings bei einem 8950 x sind wir schon bei ungefähr 1000 euro glaube ich nur
für die cpu ja ok nicht ganz 755 euro also sind wir auch bei 1000 euro wenn du dir wenn du dir
mal überlegst wenn du dir mal überlegst du kannst dir für 1000 euro kannst du dir eine
neue intel cpu kaufen plus ein mainboard und für sagen wir mal 1100 oder so in dem dreh oder
oder nie auch für ungefähr 1000 1000 bis 1100 kannst du dir eine 3950 x plus mainboard kaufen
der einfach doppelt so schnell ist multicore also irgendwie ist das bei intel grad nicht so
big brain was die machen aber was sollen sie machen die haben technik nichts zu bieten so
chrome rendert immer noch sin bench haben wir zu genau ja stimmt ich wollte gucken ob es irgendwelche
neuen linux distributionen gibt die man sich anschauen könnte aber habe ich jetzt nichts
gesehen die meisten sachen haben wir schon ausprobiert mx linux haben wir ausprobiert hat
mir überhaupt nicht gefallen manjaro verwende ich selbst hier das ist manjaro exzellent da
muss ich dir kein test zu machen mit haben wir auch schon ausprobiert mind ist echt gut kann
man empfehlen auch für neueinsteiger und bunto aber auch schon aufgab debian haben auch aufgenommen
elementary haben wir ausprobiert das fand ich glaube ich ganz ok wenn ich mich recht erinnere
elementary fand ich glaube ich ganz ok solos hatten bin ich da bin ich mir jetzt nicht mehr
sicher ich glaube solos hat mir auch ganz gut gefallen so von dem was dabei war und wie sich
so das gesamtpaket zorin haben wir auch ausprobiert das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen fedora
habe ich nicht ausprobiert weil fedora weiß ich jetzt schon gefällt mir nicht ich mache ich bin
kein rettert fern wir haben auf der arbeit rettert aber wenn ich die auswahl habe ist mir auf dem
desktop zumindest ein arch oder meinetwegen in debian und bunto immer noch lieber als
in fedora ich bin da ich einfach nicht meins soll jeder verwenden was er will open susa haben
auch ausprobiert das fand ich auch ziemlich am mist deep in die bin aber ausprobiert das fand
ich glaube ich auch gar nicht so übel aber das war halt das china linux kde neo nicht aus popos
haben wir auch schon ausprobiert da hat da hat mich irgendwas richtig gestört an popos aber ich
weiß nicht mal was ich sollte mir vielleicht diesen fazit mal so aufschreiben weiß ich
nämlich nicht mal was das gewesen ist bsd und solaris ausprobiert nein noch nicht noch nicht
und stream also ich habe die einzige erfahrung die ich mit bsd habe ist open sens bzw pf sens
und ein bisschen frinas was ich aber nie verwendet habe frinas und mit solaris habe ich so gut wie
gar keine erfahrung das einzige was ich mit solaris gemacht hat mal eine installation um
zfs features mir anzugucken anti x was ist anti x kenne ich nicht
sieht nicht sonderlich hübsch aus aber man soll es ja nicht nach den äußeren
werten beurteilen das ist eine live cd ist live cd ok hey das ist gut es gibt es gibt total wenig
gute live cds noch früher früher gab es mal knoppix aber knoppix gibt es glaube ich nicht mehr oder gibt es knoppix noch
also knoppix hat die hässlichste website und und ansonsten ist die distribution auch übelst hässlich
aber es war eine ziemlich gute live cd anscheinend gibt es knoppix noch wo kann man knoppix
downloaden ok gibt es anscheinend noch warum hält man das eigentlich nicht für notwendig bei
release notes ein datum dabei zu schreiben obs studio 22 moment obs sind wir bei welcher version
jetzt gerade 24 scheint halbwegs aktuell zu sein hast du mal das linux von intel probiert
nö popschul twitch prime exzellent dankeschön iq sub so archlinux cento s akku guck mal da ist
es ja was gerade jemand im chat folgeschlagen hat ob susa mal ausprobiert hat mir nicht gefallen
pc linux os habe ich glaube ich nie nicht ausprobiert wozu monka es monka es sage ich nur
haben wir erst in einem der letzten streams ausprobiert es hat absolut nichts funktioniert
gar nichts hat funktioniert das ist dieser dieser windows nachbau würdest du gnome kde
oder xfc empfehlen bei mancharo gar nicht gar nichts von beiden ich verwende mancharo seit
jahren und das ist jetzt echt nicht übertrieben seit ich hab verwendet seit jahren nichts anderes
mehr mancharo i3 wm beste beste kombi die es gibt i3 wm ist nicht unbedingt was für jeden also
i3 ist halt ein teilen window manager also sprich du hast keine fenster im eigentlichen
sinne sondern du hast nur fullscreen anwendung also wenn ich jetzt eine zweite anwendung aufmacht
dann geht die halt im fullscreen auf wenn ich noch eine dritte aufmacht dann teilen die sich
deshalb ich kann das aber schön teilen beziehungsweise hier verschieben und alles machen wie ich lustig
bin wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat finde ich das viel besser als fenster man kann allerdings
auch fenster modus machen in die drei also ich kann beispielsweise auch ein fenster hier draus
machen wenn man das unbedingt wenn man unbedingt fenster haben will kann man die drei auch mit
fenster verwenden für anfänger würde ich nicht empfehlen nein für anfänger würde ich die drei
nicht für mich empfehlen für anfänger finde ich ist immer noch ein linux mint mit was haben die
standardmäßig dabei cinnamon ja cinnamon ist mint mit cinnamon ist wahrscheinlich das beste wenn
du einsteigen willst gerade oder aber kde ich muss sagen ich habe früher mal eine ganze woops eine
ganze weile kde verwendet ich finde kde hat ein bisschen den anschluss verloren kde wirkt
mittlerweile total sehr zerstöckelt an an vielen stellen das menü sieht anders aus wie der editor
der editor sieht ein bisschen anders aus wie der file manager das beste an kde ist das framework
unten drunter wobei das mit kde nichts zu tun hat aber ansonsten finde ich so wirklich ansehnlich
ist kde nicht mehr ist geschmackssache ich weiß ja hat jeder so seins aber leute ich habe euch
erprediktet 2021 wird eh das jahr des linux desktop eines jahres linux desktop wird nie
kommen linux auf dem desktop wird jetzt nie geben nie es gibt eigentlich nur eine möglichkeit die
dazu führen könnte dass linux auf dem desktop irgendwie doch noch nennenswerte verbreitung
erfährt und das ist wenn irgendein großer wirklich großer hersteller also wenn jetzt sagen wir epic
games oder so was was rausbringt mit mit exklusiv mit exklusivem zeug irgendwie ja und im gleichem
zuge auch dafür sorgen würde dass andere sachen gut drauflaufen aber das ganze vergessen es das
ergibt dass das wird nicht passieren was und außerdem ist es auch gar nicht möglich also
nee wird wird wird nicht passieren
muss es aber auch nicht also für mich ist soweit gut genug dass ich seit jahren wie gesagt linux
auf dem desktop auf der arbeit verwenden kann und mir das deutlich besser gefällt als linux
windows werbung der schweizer polizei echt wo ist werbung der schweizer polizei
bewirb dich als polizist irgendwie unglückliches bild aktuell gerade
unglückliches bild gerade mit dem bein auf leuten drauf zu stehen es ist es ist das ist
gerade etwas umstritten das ist etwas es ist gerade nicht so feinfühlig drücke was mal so aus ja
was machen eigentlich so die aktuellen stellen angebote zeigen was gibt es denn so in frankfurt was
gibt es dann gerade in frankfurt so zeigt mal her was was kommen was können wir denn uns wo
können wir uns denn bewerben wo können wir uns denn bewerben also die bahn schon wieder die
bahn schon wieder ip leak ja ich liege hier laufen irgendwas die bahn ist aber voll angesagt
ja ok sap monka es ist der dark reader ist auf manchen seiten echt nicht hilfreich techniker
im rechenzentrum hey es gibt tatsächlich noch jobs mit normalen bezeichnungen die nicht super
business front-end full stack intelligence ai microservices kubernetes entwickler sind
so jobs mit normalen bezeichnungen was ist da los das glaube ich erst wenn ich sehe die
jobs verdient dass man sie mal aufmacht einen internationalen sucht maschinen betreiber also
das ist nicht was was ich wirklich machen möchte mehr sowas sowas in der richtung habe ich ja
teilweise gemacht bei meinem ersten arbeitgeber aber das ist nicht mal so das aber immerhin mal
eine stellenanzeige mit ordentlichem titel was ist ein mwf das ist eine gute frage männlich weiblich
f fluid wahrscheinlich die machen was wollen nicht das nicht dass jetzt gleich die anzeige raus ist die
ist neben dem f vielleicht haben sie sich einfach auch nur vertippt aber ansonsten finde ich die
stellenanzeige nicht so ich mein so wirklich überzeugend naja also was haben wir sonst
noch schönes zu bieten in frankfurt als was suchen wir mal also das ist das was ich aktuell mache
es ein bisschen doof in der it muss man sagen es gibt so unglaublich viele bezeichnungen für
stellen du kannst eigentlich gar nicht wirklich nach irgendwas speziell im suchen
wuhu der name klingt ein wenig cringe irgendwie das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken wuhu germany
wuhu wuhu die heißen wirklich so ok easy light sagt ja und gefühlt versteht auch noch jeder
unter dem gleichen begriff was anderes das ist richtig lust auf berufliche veränderung finden
sie heraus was sie verdienen können kostenlos und anonym excellent ok das machen wir jetzt mal
das machen wir jetzt mal gucken mal gucken was da rauskommt anonym und und in fünf minuten also
frage und fester art der beschäftigung ja teilzeit weil weil ich habe ja nur wie viele
arbeitsstunden pro woche habe ich eigentlich glaube 30 bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher wie viele
arbeitsstunden pro woche ich habe ja ich glaube 30 ich glaube 30 ich glaube 30 ja doch ich habe
vier mal vier mal 7,84 oder irgendwie sowas doch irgendwie so also das da 31 31,36 arbeitsstunden
habe ich pro woche oder 7,75 ja kann auch sein 7,75 31 ok excellent 7,48 ich weiß es nicht genau ich
mache jetzt einfach mal 30 ich habe echt keine oder 31 ich habe wirklich keine ahnung wie viel
es genau sind ich gucke ich arbeite aktuell von 7,30 ungefähr so bis 16 nur normalerweise
normalerweise immer wenn ich morgen wenn ich kein home office ab so von 7 bis 15 30 irgendwie
so in dem drehacht passt schon ok ja und wie das kann ich wie alles weiß ich doch aus dem
kopf jetzt nicht ich dachte ihr wollt mir das ausrechnen wie viel ich verdienen kann ohne
variable bezüge provision bonus ok da müssen wir eine tarife halte in der tarif
wie ist diese komische tarifvertrag versicherung hier die da tarifvertrag
das da wo sind die gehaltstabellen ich kann euch ich darf euch nicht genau sagen was ich
verdiene aber die gehaltstabelle darf ich zeigen wo ist er denn überhaupt
das da das da ok achso moment es sind ja nur es sind ja nur vier tage die woche ok das da
moment kann man das nicht warum kann man das nicht copy pasten excellent geht nicht also
4 3 2 1 übrigens tolle tolle mal 14 und das ganze dann durch wie rechne ich das jetzt auch
aus big brain leute wie rechne ich denn das hier aus auf vier tage auf auf 80 prozenter
im endeffekt mal 0,8 ok das darf ich euch zeigen weil das ist ja im prinzip das was
im tarifvertrag drin steht das ist ja nichts geheimes so dein ernst ja was jetzt weil
ich jetzt hier die quickmaps nicht hingekriegt habe oder wie oder was warum wäre ich hier
wieder geflamet was ist hier los bigmaps quickmaps so variable bezüge ja das darf das das kann ich
euch jetzt eigentlich nicht verraten wieso mal 14 weil ich weil weil wir 14 monate geld kriegen
ja das darf ich euch jetzt nicht verraten achso
egal wir lassen es jetzt einfach mal gucken wie zufrieden sind sie mit ihrem derzeitigen
halt naja wir machen jetzt mal einfach eher unzufrieden weil ich will ja mehr geld und
ich will wissen was stepstone mir sagen kann was ich ans verdienen kann job titel ok ich will
einfach mal gucken was da rauskommt standort ihres arbeitgeber 60329 achso frankfurt am main
es ist mir scheiß egal ob das unwirksam ist oder nicht ich werde jetzt bestimmt ich werde
jetzt bestimmt nicht einfach irgendwas erzählen obwohl drinne steht dass ich nicht erzählen
darf für mich ist mir vollkommen egal ob das ungültig ist oder nicht berufs relevante
qualifikationen fachkenntnisse ok ja ja ist jetzt kein analyst mach wirklich diesen fall ja ja ja ja
Ja, ein bisschen auch mehr fähig kann, wie mehr gibt's nicht?
Was ist mit dem ganzen Rest?
Ruby, Ruby, was soll ich ja sonst noch alles angeben?
C Sharp, Linux, Linux, ja, da kannste, da bin ich ja jetzt 3 Stunden
beschäftigt, wenn ich da alles eintrage. Da bin ich ja jetzt ewig beschäftigt, wenn ich da
alles eintrage. UJS, Java Script, ASP.NET Core, gibt's nicht, da kann ich doch jetzt,
das dauert doch Stunden, bis ich da alles eingetragen hab. CSS, HTML, HTML 6 sogar.
Ey, da brauch ich ewig, bis ich da Zeugs eingetragen hab. Komm, wir sehen das mal ganz
hart drauf, C++, Alter. Ey, ich kann ASP32 programmieren, ja. Cobol, Cobol. Was,
ASMA, genau. Ey, da brauch ich jetzt ewig, bis ich das ausgefüllt hab. Mal gucken, mal gucken,
WIM, WIM, WIM, EMAX, Visual Studio, gibt's auch VS Code? Alter, da kannst du, also, wenn
ich da alles, wenn ich da PHP, ja, hatte ich auch schon PHP mit Laravel, wenn ich da wirklich
alles rein schreibe das dauert stunden azure azure muss da rein azure azure azure cloud
jawoll ich kenne mich auch mit hardware und rechtzentrum kram aus und
egal wir lassen wir lassen das jetzt mal gibt es eigentlich raspberry
die gibt es da nicht
pfleg teppich herstellung ah ja moment was märchen märchen therapie ja das ist in der
it auch recht verbreitet ja youtube twitch obs oh nee in flue in fluenza
social media ich kann euch sowas von beraten zu social media es klappt ja gar nicht egal
wir lassen es jetzt einfach mal berufserfahrung ohne ausbildung und praktikumszeit zehn jahre
2007 13 jahre manche branche ihres derzeitigen aber es gibt versicherung bank bank bank und
versicherung ja was denn jetzt kann ich zwei sachen angeben es ist eigentlich eine bank
aber wir sind wir zählen zu versicherung ja lassen wir einfach mal nimmt wahrscheinlich
kein großartigen unterschied anzahl der mitarbeiter im unternehmen ich glaube so in dem dreh kommt
hin weiß ich gar nicht genau keine management auf gar keinen fall hör mal auf nein nein
nein nein nein kommt mir nicht mit management kram da ist da ist die grenze erreicht irgendwo
hat er spaß auf irgendwo hat er spaß auf höchster bildungsabschluss nee zählt das
oder mal ja das ausbildungsjahr geburts geburtsjahr gut das ist kein kein geheimnis 1984 chat
ich finde mich hier nicht wieder kein helikopter ja das mag sein wenn es das gehaltet aber
ich mache ich werde nie freiwillig management sachen machen nie was ihr dreck säcke alter
ich habe den ganzen scheiß ausgefüllt jetzt soll ich mich registrieren ihr dreck säcke
ey das ist doch nicht normal 10 minute mail easy was war das richtige das hier ne zdm was
gibt ihr vorher wir haben die
registrieren
save ok
und wo habe ich es jetzt?
und wo kriege ich jetzt die, wo kriege ich jetzt die Ergebnisse von der Umt... von der Umfrage?
gebate?
profil vervollständigen
ah
weiter
ja
ey
das habt ihr mir aber was anderes erzählt
da habt ihr mir aber was anderes erzählt
hä?
warum ist das jetzt weg?
premium feature wahrscheinlich
hallo?
hey
was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
hä?
ok, kompletter useless crap alter
ok
dann wisst ihr was?
dann logge ich mich jetzt aus, wir machen das hier zu
ich gehe in die settings und lösche browser data und die letzte Stunde und zack alles ist wieder weg
so also wuhu waren wir gerade
was hat wuhu zu bieten?
ähm also so wer ist das denn? wuhu
wuhu so heißen wir nicht nur sondern diese Begeisterung wollen wir auch bei dir wecken
oh der intro schmerzt schon ein bisschen
ok
als erfahrener engineering Dienstleister unterstützen wir Unternehmen mit Spezialisten in technischen Projekten
wir bringen deine Karriere voran
was ist das Personalverschacherungs Ding?
das ist so ein Personalvermittlungs Ding oder?
wenn ich sowas hier lese als erfahrener engineering Dienstleister unterstützen wir Unternehmen mit Spezialisten in technischen Projekten
wir bringen deine Karriere voran denn bei uns stehst du im Fokus
ob absolvent young professional
wisst ihr wie sich young professional anhört?
das hört sich irgendwie was an wie einer der vorher Pornhub gemacht hat oder so
ich bin young professional
oder erfahrene Fachkraft wir sehen dich als Persönlichkeit bla bla bla
seht ich bin euch also eins können wir mal eins können wir mal jetzt festhalten
ich persönlich bin denen genauso scheiß egal wie alle anderen auch
die wollen Geld mit mir verdienen
das ist alles ich bin denen persönlich vollkommen egal das muss einem klar sein
so können wir dich umfassend beraten und vielleicht noch mit Positionen die zu dir bla bla bla
wir sind eine Tochter der Mandak was auch immer das ist was ist das?
was niederländisches alles klar exzellent
das bedeutet ja bla bla bla bla 30 jahre bla bla bla
wir suchen ein devops engine für ein Projekt dabei
ok es ist Personalvermietungsgedöns also sprich die suchen auf einer
jetzt überlegt ihr mal jetzt überlegt mal wieviel durch wieviel Hände euer Gehalt geht bei dieser Sache
na was heißt euer Gehalt?
durch wieviel Hände euer ihr Gehfasi geht
erstmal möchte stepstone was verdienen
dann möchte wuhu was verdienen
nachdem also stepstone vermittelt euch wuhu stellt euch dann irgendwie ein und wuhu vermittelt euch
das heißt die beiden wollen schon was dran verdienen
und der wo ihr letztendlich landet der möchte natürlich auch was dran verdienen dass ihr da seid
also da bleibt für euch wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so viel übrig
was was erzählen sie denn hier?
meine Noten waren sehr schlecht
ich hab nur einen Realschulabschluss gemacht
und danach hab ich irgendwann eine Ausbildung angefangen
meine Noten beim Realschulabschluss waren absolut scheiße
ich hab ja schon oft gesagt ich hab einfach nur so viel wie nötig gemacht
matze fragt max ich bin fast mit meiner Ausbildung als fisi fertig und suche nebenbei einer Stelle
was ich komisch finde ist dass die gleichen Leute suchen die fast alles können was denken die sich?
die denken sich nichts
Stellenanzeigen werden von Kacknoobs geschrieben die keine Ahnung haben
Stellenanzeigen werden meistens von irgendwelchen Personal oder Management Stonksleuten geschrieben
die keinen blassen Schimmer haben was die jeweiligen Abteilungen eigentlich haben wollen
deswegen kannst du auf Stellenanzeigen eigentlich so gut wie gar leider so gut wie gar nichts geben
ist übrigens dort wo ich arbeite auch nicht viel anders
also was haben sie denn hier stehen?
als DevOps Engineer bist du zuständig für die Konzeption, Implementierung und den Betrieb von Enterprise Service Management Lösung
oh das klingt natürlich schonmal toll
sowie für die Konfiguration, Weitergabe von Modulen, die Entwicklung von Kundenportalen und für das Skripting von Workflows
such dir nicht zufällig einen Entwickler
Du bist die Schnittstelle von den betreffenden Abteilungen, hältst diese auf dem aktuellen Stand und koordinierst
Moment was?
Ich soll Abteilungen koordinieren? Lese ich das gerade richtig?
Nee oder? Das lese ich falsch, aber das sagt der Satz, das meinen die bestimmt nicht, aber das sagt der Satz
weil wenn das so wäre suchen sie irgendeinen Management Mensch
Die Kundenberatung bei Technik und fachlichen Fragen fällt auch in der Hand
Was? Die wollen ja alles haben
Auch die Entwicklung von Konzepten für Automatisierung, Betrieb und Monitoring koordinierst du
Ok, das lass ich mir noch gefallen, das ergibt irgendwie Sinn
Also irgendwie wissen die nicht so genau was die haben wollen glaube ich
Die wollen einen Entwickler haben, die wollen irgendeinen Management Koordinator Mensch haben
Die wollen jemanden haben der Endkunden fast schon so eine Art Sales-Gedöns mitmacht
Dann für Monitoring, Automatisierung, ja das ergibt Sinn
Und dann irgendwelche Zusammenarbeit mit Software-Lieferanten
Ok, also das hier ist das einzige wo ich sagen würde, ja das passt gut rein
Und auch Schnittstelle zwischen Entwicklung und Administration passt auch gut rein, aber das steht ja eigentlich gar nicht
Äh, was?
Boombada Bingdings Bums schreibt, wir hatten mal eine mit dem Satz
Erwünscht sind Kenntnisse der Internetstandards
Ach der internen Standard, was?
Gewünscht sind Kenntnisse der internen Standards?
Das ist ja aber echt bescheuert sowas reinzuschreiben
Ok, also was wollen sie?
Bringst du ein abgeschlossenes Studio mit oder verfügst du, ja ja bla bla bla, im Endeffekt ist das euch vollkommen wurscht
Du verfügst über mehrere Berufserfahrungen im Bereich der Informatik und der Softwareentwicklung, ja
Die gängigen Methoden und Tools in der Softwareentwicklung beherrschst du souverän und bist vertraut im Betrieb in der Cloud
Das ist sowas von vage geschrieben
Ich mein, die gängigen Tools und die gängigen Methoden und Tools in der Softwareentwicklung
Das ist alles und nichts
Das einzige was mir einfällt ist Git
Git ist mittlerweile so verbreitet, dass passt
Ja, sowas wie vielleicht noch Visual Studio Code, meinetwegen ist auch mittlerweile relativ verbreitet
Ein bisschen Linux Basic sollte auch jeder können
Aber ansonsten ist das komplett alles und nichts, diese Beschreibung
Die sieht komplett anders aus, wenn du beispielsweise Java entwickelst
Wie wenn du eine ASP.NET Core Anwendung mit JavaScript entwickelst
Das ist komplett, komplett anders
So, und Betrieb in der Cloud, ja
Kann man so hinschreiben, aber es ist auch sehr vage, ja
Die Cloud, es ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwie jetzt was Spezielles aussagen würde
Ok, JavaScript, AngularJS und Jelly sind die Basis für deine Aufgaben
Ok, da falle ich schon mal raus, JavaScript, ja
AngularJS, äh ne, AngularJS, ist AngularJS nicht, nicht, gibt es das nicht mehr?
Haben die das nicht eingestellt?
Gibt es jetzt nicht nur noch Angular?
Aber ich glaub, die sind nicht so aktuell
Ich glaub, das ist hier, äh, RIP bei Google, Angular gibt's doch gar nicht mehr
Angular, ja, AngularJS ist dead
Aber das wissen die wahrscheinlich, die sind wahrscheinlich nicht so auf dem aktuellen Stand, den die Bewerbung geschrieben hat
Jelly, was ist Jelly?
Hab ich noch nie gehört, was ist Jelly?
Guck mal, such mal ein Jelly-Java-Skript
Was ist das?
Was ist Jelly?
XML-Base-Skripting-Engine
Ja, geh mal fort, alter
So, ähm
Also, ganz ehrlich, JavaScript, ja, AngularJS, nicht wirklich, Jelly, keine Ahnung, was das ist
Automatisierung, Softwareentwicklung, bis zum Mittwoch
Automatisierung, Softwareentwicklung, bis zum Betrieb von Applikationen, ja
Wichtig ist, dass du Spaß an der Arbeit in Teams hast
Und dieses Antreiben
Und gemeinsamer viele Ziele vorantreiben kannst
Ja, was jetzt?
Ihr wollt, ihr wollt so eine Mischung, ihr wollt eigentlich jemand, der alles kann
Jetzt sollst du auch noch Managementgeschichten machen
Dabei helfen dir deine Erfahrungen mit...
Die lassen nichts aus, die lassen nichts aus
Die lassen nichts aus, alter
Scrum und Agilen, Agile-Arbeitsweisen
Fließende Deutschkenntnisse runden dein Profil ab, da darf derjenige aber nicht mal in Stream gucken
Ich rede ja hier kein Deutsch, ich rede so eine Mischung aus
Deutsche Wörter mit Twitch, Emotes und englischen Wörtern
Also ich glaube, so wirklich als Deutsch geht das hier kaum noch durch, oder?
Das ist doch...
Das ist eigentlich der eigene Sprache
Twitch auch nicht, oder so
Ja, aber Wolle1508, den Kram schreiben sie überall hin
Das ist doch geil
Scrim, Scrum, nicht Scrim, wir wollen jetzt hier kein Competitive Zeug starten
Scrum, ITIL, Agile, ähm, wie heißt das andere?
ISO 9001, oder so?
Oh, wie heißt das ISO 9001? War das ISO 9001?
Ja, den Scheiß gibt's auch noch, oh, hör mal auf, ey
Dass da gar kein ITIL drinne steht, das hätte ich jetzt eigentlich erwartet
Das ITIL muss da eigentlich noch rein, das schreiben sie auch alle rein
Übrigens, eine Sache muss ich jetzt hier nochmal sagen, weil es mich gerade wieder dran erinnert hat
Hier, wichtig ist, dass du Spaß an der Arbeit in Teams hast
Das ist heute tatsächlich wichtig, aber die meisten...
Okay, das stimmt, das kann ich so nicht sagen, weil ich hab nicht wirklich großartige Erfahrungen
Ich war bisher bei zwei unterschiedlichen Arbeitgebern, ja
Also, ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich da jetzt aus Erfahrung sprechen könnte, so nach dem Motto
Ey, es ist überall so
Aber es ist zumindest der Eindruck, der sich mir aufdrängt, ist, dass viele Schreiben
Wichtig ist, dass du Spaß an der Arbeit im Team hast, aber unterm Strich
Das gar nicht zählt
Was ich meine ist, dass zum Beispiel gesagt wird, oh ja, Teamarbeit furchtbar wichtig
Und es gibt Leute, die bringen sie auch richtig ein, machen Vorschläge
Sorgen dafür, dass Sachen besser werden, bringen Verbesserungsvorschläge ein
Optimieren irgendwelche Sachen, also sind richtige Teamplayer
Aber wenn es dann um die Frage geht, wer kriegt mehr Kohle
Dann kriegt nicht der Teamplayer mehr Kohle, sondern derjenige, der im Alleingang
Irgend ein komisches Aushängeschildprojekt durchgedrückt hat
Also, ich persönlich hab den Eindruck, viele schreiben, sie wollen Teamplayer haben
Aber ihre Taten sprechen nicht so wirklich dafür, um es mal so auszudrücken
Ich weiß, es gibt bestimmt bessere Beispiele dafür
Aber trotzdem ist das wichtig, also alleine sonnerlich weit kommst du heute nicht mehr
Easy Light, so ist das bei uns auch
Aber jetzt ist die Frage, wie das bei euch läuft
Würden die jetzt bei euch sagen, hey guck mal, ihr seid ja ein super Team
Ihr kriegt jetzt alle sechs mehr Geld, oder kriegt vielleicht irgendjemand mehr Geld
Der einfach nur einen besonders wichtigen Eindruck macht
Und immer besonders viel schwätzt auf irgendwelchen Meetings und Runden
Wer kriegt mehr Kohle? Euer Team, weil es gute Arbeit abliefert, ihr gut zusammenarbeitet
Ihr ein gutes Team seid, oder der eine, der einfach immer auf dicke Hose macht
Und ich hab den Eindruck, dass viele sagen, sie wollen Teamplayer
Aber die unter dem Strich dann belohnt werden eigentlich sind nicht die Teamplayer
Was merkwürdig ist
Also, sie sagen, sie wollen Teamplayer haben, aber belohnt werden die nicht Teamplayer
Das ist merkwürdig
Also das heißt, im Prinzip ist das einfach nur eine Floskel, die man raushaut ohne Sinn
Ich will nicht sagen, dass das überall so ist
Ich kann ja auch persönlich gar nicht großartig aus Erfahrung sprechen
Ich war ja nicht bei so vielen Läden
So, also was haben wir noch? Also Informatiker als DevOps
Also Bahn hatten wir uns schonmal angeguckt, Bahn war jetzt nicht so spannend
Bits... Moment, was?
Der Bits DevOps, das hab ich auch noch nicht gelesen
Ist das der Business DevOps? Mit dem Business die digitale Transformation
Was ein Bullshit Satz, Alter
Im Sinne eines Bits DevOps Ansatzes hast du den Anspruch, gemeinsam mit dem Business die digitale Transformation voranzutreiben
Das ist wieder so ein Satz, das sagt absolut nichts aus
Was soll dieser Satz überhaupt bedeuten?
Was heißt dieser Satz überhaupt?
Man weiß es nicht genau
Okay, wir gucken uns doch jetzt mal eins von der Bahn an
Blablabla
Du arbeitest agil in einem DevOps Team und setzt gemeinsam mit deinen Kollegen eine funktionierende, effiziente Continuous Delivery Pipeline im Projekt
Krass hier, da gehts ab
Was damit gemeint ist, ich versuch das mal in normale Worte zu packen
Was sie damit meinen ist, dass der Zyklus von einem Feature wird entwickelt, zu einem Feature wird live eingeführt, möglichst kurz ist
Das meinen die damit
Effiziente Continuous Delivery Pipeline
Also zum Beispiel in der Bahn App
Ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal als Beispiel, weil es jeder kennt
In der Bahn App entwickelt jetzt jemand ein neues Feature oder sagt mal irgendjemand sagt, das wäre eine gute Idee
Wenn auf der Map in der Bahn App jetzt das Gelb plinken würde, random
Und das Bahn Management sagt, wir wollten schon immer random gelb plinken haben auf der Map
Dann programmiert einer das random gelb plinken und dann sorgt eine effiziente Continuous Delivery Pipeline dafür, dass dieses random gelb plinken Feature möglichst schnell und ohne viel drumherum zu beeinflussen live in die Bahn App kommt
Das meinen die mit effiziente Continuous Delivery Pipeline
Die meinen damit nicht, dass Züge pünktlich sind oder sowas, das wäre ja nicht auszudenken
Du nutzt gemeinsam mit deinem Team die Möglichkeit der Cloud, sowohl für die Entwicklung der Produkte als auch für die Etablierung, was für die Etablierung optimierter Abläufe, ok
Ziemlich nichtsagender Satz
Dadurch, dass du das erklären konntest, bist du schon eingestellt
Ich glaube die meisten Leute würden wirklich vor dem Satz erst mal sitzen
Aber ich hatte das Glück, ich habe ja schon ein paar dieser Bullshit-Dinger hier auch öfters im Stream gelesen
Die meisten Dinge kenne ich mittlerweile, die so an Sprüchen kommen
Aber Leute, die sich in dem Bereich auskennen, sollten zumindest eine Idee haben, was mit Continuous Delivery Pipeline gemeint ist
Du hast also eine Web App, die mit der Jenkins Pipeline deployed wird
Zum Beispiel, das ist ja nur ein Fall davon, allerdings spielt ja noch ein bisschen mehr rein
Je nachdem, wie umfangreich dein Jenkins Job ist
Du musst ja manchmal vielleicht auch noch eine QS-Abnahme machen und sowas
Damit ist im Prinzip nur gemeint, dass es möglichst schnell geht
Vom Feature wird es sich ausgedacht, zu Feature ist in der App drinne
Und möglichst wenig drumherum kaputt zu machen
Ok, das war absolut nichts sagen
Du übernimmst Verantwortung vom Feature über Architektur, Design, Programmierung, Test bis hin...
Watt, ich soll alles machen?
Ich soll alles machen?
Architektur, Design, Programmierung, Test?
Was zum Geier ist mit euch los?
Das sind mindestens vier Jobs in einem
Das ist jetzt nicht... Das kann doch nicht den hier in Ernst sein
Der Rest hat sich bisher nach normalem Blabla, aber das ist absolut unrealistischer Schwachsinn
Architektur ist ein Job, Design ist ein Job, Programmieren ist ein Job und Testen ist ein Job
Nicht nur machen, sondern auch verantworten
Und man muss auch sagen, gerade Programmierer sind nicht unbedingt die besten Designer
Und umgedreht sind Designer so gut wie nie Programmierer
Also jetzt ohne Designer flamen zu wollen, ich behaupte mal
Die Fähigkeit von Programmierern was zu designen ist besser als von Designern was zu programmieren
Das was Programmierer designen sieht nicht absolut vergoldet aus im Endeffekt
Aber es ist benutzbar, also jemand, beispielsweise ein Frontend Entwickler kann auch eine Webseite halbwegs hübsch machen
Allerdings ein Designer, der eine hübsche Webseite in Photoshop entwerfen kann, kann im Leben nicht programmieren
Oder die wenigsten
Also sie wollen echt alles
Du brennst... Oh jetzt gehts los hier
Muss ich auch noch brennen ne
Du brennst für effiziente Methoden und Prozess
Was?
Soll das nicht Prozesse heißen?
Für effiziente Methoden und Prozesse
Oder ist mein Deutsch einfach nicht gut genug für um das zu verstehen
Du brennst für effiziente Methoden und Prozess
Und nutzt jede Gelegenheit, aber vielleicht haben die nur einen Prozess
Das kann natürlich auch sein, wenn die nur einen Prozess haben, dann ergibt das Sinn
Und nutzt jede Gelegenheit Abläufe durch Automatisierung zu optimieren
Softwareentwicklung im Betrieb definierst du nicht nur technisch, sondern entwickelst Lösungen, die das Feedback der Endanwender von die kontinuierliche Verbesserung nutzbar machen
Was?
Wer schreibt den Kram, wenn man da schmilzt mir das Gehirn dabei
Softwareentwicklung, sondern entwickelst Lösungen, die das Feedback der Endanwender für kontinuierliche Verbesserung nutzbar machen
Also im Prinzip sollst du jetzt nicht nur Architektur machen, Design machen, Programmierung abmachen, testen
Nein, du sollst auch noch irgendwie Endanwender Feedback verarbeiten oder so
Du trägst aktiv zu schnell nutzbaren Ergebnissen bei, bist bereit auch Rückschläge in Kauf zu machen, hast immer das Ziel im Blick
Also die suchen im Prinzip wieder mindestens vier bis fünf Jobs in einem hier bei der Bahn gerade
Neben guten Englischen bringst du vor allem Fleece in Deutsch, da ist es wieder, da ist es wieder, Fleece in Deutsch Kenntnisse, ja das kann man so nicht sagen
Und gute Englisch Kenntnisse handhabe ich wieder Oettinger, ich sag einfach nur we are all sitting in one boat
Das überzeugt schon, das geht als gute Englisch Kenntnisse durch
Du gehst bei Bedarf auch unkonventionelle Wege und brennst für neue innovative technische Lösungen, das widerspricht sich ein bisschen
Hier oben soll ich brennen für ihre Prozesse und hier unten soll ich unkonventionelle Wege gehen
Unkonventionelle Wege sind in der Regel nicht in irgendwelchen Prozessen drin
Also immer, beschweren wir uns mal nicht weiter
Ok Benefits, was bieten sie einem dann Schönes?
Ich hab übrigens gar nicht geguckt was Woohoo uns bietet
Benefits, also sprich Vorteile die ich habe
Du schaffst Großes und bekommst nicht weniger zurück
Ok, ein marktübliches Gehaltspaket
Ok, geil oder? Du schaffst Großes und bekommst nicht weniger zurück
Ein marktübliches Gehaltspaket, also normal
Fängt schon gut an
Mit in der Regel unbefristeten Arbeitsverdringungen und Beschäftigungssicherungen
So wie vielfältige Nebenleistungen, eine betriebliche Alterswahl
Das kann tatsächlich ganz gut sein
Faszinierende Projekte und Aufgaben
Ey, das ist für mich doch erstmal zweitrangig
Ich mein es ist cool, aber nicht wirklich Benefits in dem Sinn
Benefits für mich sind zum Beispiel entweder ich krieg richtig viel Geld
Oder wir haben eine Kantine im Haus oder für die Leute die Kinder haben
Es gibt Kinderbetreuung oder sowas sind Benefits
Es gibt ein Ticket das du umsonst mit der Bahn fahren kannst
Wenn du schon bei der Bahn arbeitest, irgendwie sowas ja
Aber wahrscheinlich wollen die gar nicht dass ihre eigenen Leute mit der Bahn fahren
Ist es denn eine gute Ausrede wenn man bei der Bahn arbeitet
Und mit der Bahn zum Job fährt zu sagen
Ich konnte heute nicht pünktlich kommen weil die Bahn zu spät war
Da kann sich doch gar
Wenn man bei der Bahn arbeitet kann sich da doch keiner beschweren
Das ist ja quasi
Wenn die sich darüber beschweren
Hinterfragen sie quasi ihre eigene Existenz
Also wenn du bei der Bahn arbeitest und dein Chef bei der Bahn
Beschwert sich wenn du wegen der Bahn zu spät auf die Arbeit kommst
Das ist so Inception
Das ist so quasi
Die lösen sich instant in Luft auf
Bei der Frage
Von der Digitalisierung eines Großkonzerns
Bis zum Projekt Zukunft Bahn
Fordere dein Können und warte auf deine Handschritte
Das ist doch kein Benefit
Das ist Benefit für die Bahn aber doch nicht für mich
Das ist gut
Dabei ist es total
Ich glaube das hat der Serious Max in zwei Minuten zusammengepaint
Gezielte und individuelle
Weiterentwicklungsmöglichkeit für Fachprojekte
Okay im Endeffekt halten wir fest
Es gibt so gut wie keine Benefits
Hast du schon mal den CCC Talk zu den Bahn Apis gesehen
Ja habe ich habe ich
Guckt schon
Du schaffst Großes und bekommst weniger zurück
Ja so ungefähr liest sich das
Weiter Allianz das ist gar nicht so weit weg
Von uns das ist quasi die Konkurrenz
So
Was suchen was suchen die dann
Oh die sind die sind voll am Puls der Zeit ist es nicht
MWD ist es FMD
Okay die übliche Einleitungs
Introduction die man sich sparen kann
Wo einfach nur drin steht wie toll der Arbeitgeber ist
Stimmt das sind jetzt ja auf einmal auf Englisch
Wann waren die anderen auch auf Englisch
Ne die anderen waren auf Deutsch
Also
Man wird hier für das IT
Delivery Transformation Team in Frankfurt gesucht
Wildbett nur zum Spaß
Also IT Delivery
Transformation Team in Frankfurt
So DevOps Transformation und Implementation
Ich hab bei besten Welt keine Ahnung was eine
DevOps Transformation Ach so
Versteh ich was die mir sagen wollen
Die wollen quasi
Du sollst nichts transformieren in dem Sinn
Die versuchen gerade sich selbst
Quasi neu aufzustellen glaube ich soll das heißt
Also sie durchlaufen gerade eine Transformation
Von Alt zu einer DevOps Transformation
Da sollst du mithelfen so verstehe ich das jetzt gerade
IT Delivery Transformation
Das sind sechs Leute
Warum müssen sechs Leute über die ganze
Welt verteilt sein
London Paris Hongkong New York Dallas
Moment ist sechs Leute
Oder sind sechs unterschiedliche
Zwei Zonen
Oh da bin ich ja mal gespannt wie das funktioniert
Ne auch nicht oder
Also
Ja und bald Frankfurt Frankfurt
London Paris ok wenigstens
Ist London Paris Frankfurt halbwegs in der gleichen
Zeitzone Hongkong New York und Dallas
Ok da bin ich ja echt mal gespannt
Also ich will da nicht hin
Da bin ich echt mal gespannt wie das funktioniert
Du kannst ja mit deinen Teammitglieder
Nie richtig kommunizieren
Die schlafen ja zum größten Teil wenn du wach bist umgedreht
Jede Stadt hat ein Team mit sechs
Echt? Ne oder
Globally distributed team with six members
Ne ne es sind sechs
Insgesamt in diesem globalen
Team anders kann man das eigentlich
Nicht lesen oder chat
Also ich glaube nicht dass das heißen soll dass es sechs pro Standort sind
Du arbeitest einfach 18 Stunden pro Tag
Da gibt es Überschreitungen exzellent Idee
Lektos live moin
Das könnte tatsächlich sein dass das so gedacht ist
Ich muss mal kurz husten
Exzellent
Ok was soll man als nächstes machen
Ups hab den Chat zugemacht aus Versehen
Ah das kann natürlich sein
Die meinen sechs Members die meinen nicht Leute
Die meinen sechs Standorte vielleicht
Ach was auch immer ist doch scheißegal
Establishing new devops culture
Stimmt das was ich oben gelesen hab
Blablabla
Ok also was macht man
Work as technical devops engineer design building full stack devops solutions
For business critical applications
Das sagt jeder jede Firma jedes Unternehmen sagt
Unsere Sachen sind business critical
Ja und am besten alle sind business critical
Ist bei uns auch so
Was eigentlich lustig ist manche Sachen werden total
Mit heißer Nadel gestrickt eingeführt
Überhaupt nichts redet und dann nichts ordentlich aufgebaut
Nichts dokumentiert und dann kommt irgendeiner um die Ecke und sagt
Das ist jetzt kritisch
So im Moment das war doch eben noch mit heißer Nadel
Gestrickter Testbetrieb ja das ist jetzt live das ist kritisch
Denke ich mir auch immer
Ist klar Leute
Ok das ist
Promotion
Blablabla
Das ist langweilig
Across multiple globally located teams
Nee da hab ich eigentlich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
Blablabla
Skills
End to end technical devops experience
In Azure cloud and data center environments
Aha end to end
Ohje Training hör mal auf
Bloß nicht da muss man mit Menschen arbeiten
In die Tüte
Wie GitHub
Wie war es nochmal
Chit Chit Hub heißt ja
Ganz vergessen
Chit Hub heißt ja laut
Laut Spiegel oder Welt
Chit Chit Hub
Azure
One understanding of building a binary
What
Build and build
Build and package management together
Ok jetzt ergibt das Sinn alles klar
Automated Test Frame
Es klingt extrem stark nach Java
Wenn ich hier Nexus, Maven und Ant lese
Das ist sowas von sich her Java
Das ist
Gibt keine Zweifel mehr
Experience automated provisioning
Blablablabla
Docker Swarm
Das wird doch gar nicht verwendet
Also bei den drei Sachen
Mit Chef habe ich nun ganz kurz was gemacht
Puppet kenne ich mich ganz gut aus
Terraform ist ja der neueste Shit
Genauso wie Coop trees
Wobei man halt sagen muss
sind keine configuration management tools nur die ersten beiden, nur die ersten drei
okay das ist lang, ah what we offer also nix oder was we offer was ist das für ein schwachsinnstext
ihr offert im endeffekt nix da steht nichts drinne was jetzt irgendwie vorteilhaft für
mich wäre okay weg ich wollte noch gucken was wuhu liefert ah gar nichts man hat gar
keine vorteile connected car projekte volkswagen waren die das nicht das waren die mit dem
abgas zeug oder ich kenne mich bei autos nicht aus das waren die mit dem abgas kamer
die kernthemen sind big data elektromobilität autonomes fahren und vernetzte plattform
aha das ist ja eigentlich ganz cool diese aufgaben erwarten sie sind teil des scrum
teams natürlich was sonst und verantworten die umsetzung skalierbarer cloud architekturen
ich ich warte noch darauf wo hier rein steht die diese aufgabe warten sie wurde da drinnen
steht wo plus per twitch prime abonnieren das das wäre noch mal was da würde ich mich
tatsächlich direkt bewerben also scrum muss natürlich sein ohne scrum und agile geht
nix technische beratung des eigenen und kundenseitigen teams blab in moderne was beziehung moderner
operations konzepte darf man auch vom eigen arbeitgeber die jobs vorstellen klar kannst
du machen fünf drei fünf zwei monat dankeschön excellent hi iq subscription aktive mitgestandene
defops kultur automatisierung ok das geht tatsächlich man das rest ist bla bla aber die zwei sachen
sind doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll hier
als idealer bewerber bringen sie praktische defops erfahrung ja erfahrung mit container
cloud infrastructure und datenbanken ja datenbanken nicht so viel aber geht kendeness in kopanitis
mit amazon webservice amazon webservice ist die einzige cloud mit der ich noch so gut
wie nichts gemacht habe google cloud kenne ich mich ganz gut aus azure geht so geht auch
ganz gut aber amazon habe ich nix gemacht
nein das ist das ist nur aus das ist nur aus spaß an der freude ich suche keine ich suche
nicht wirklich einen neuen job ne ne was axo.de jobs kann ich machen ja können wir uns gleich
mal angucken also das job angebot von silence kills me schauen wir uns das mal an zusammen
teile vom ganzen sein ein gutes gefühl ich finde ja so sachen immer es ist geschmackssache
ich will nicht sagen dass es schlecht ist ja ich will nicht sagen dass schlecht ist eine
sache die mir die mir halt auch bei den arbeitgeber da war wo ich bisher wo ich bisher selbst gewesen
bin die haben alle so auf auf familie gemacht und ich bin halt ich bin da nicht der richtige
mensch für ja ich bin da echt nicht der richtige mensch für weil ich brauche also meine kollegen
müssen nicht meine familie sein so irgendwie allerdings ist familie noch ganz gutes ganz
gutes stichwort zum glück sagen sie nicht freunde weil freunde kann man sich aussuchen
familie nicht ok also was werde axo laut das ist gar nicht schlecht ist automatisierte
software integration trivial was das für eine frage ne da ist die meisten sachen sind
nicht trivial ok also das finde ich eigentlich ganz lustig es ist so ein bisschen der trend
von us us ja genau das wollte ich auch sagen ein bisschen so der trend wie bei kokona start
ups die nennen auch ihre ihre mitarbeiter so gerne nach nach irgendwie dem unternehmen
namen und so ok axonauten das sind wir ein hochkarätiges einverantwortliches pragmatisches
und kundenorientiert alles perfekt das weiter wächst wir suchen die besten auf ihrem jeweiligen
gebiet das ist gut wacher und könner mit verschiedenen qualifikationen der text ist
zumindest wenigstens mal halbwegs normal geschrieben ja nicht so dieses dieses total wie so ist
dieses moment hier sowas hier nicht so dieses total unpersönliche lehre fülltext wie hier
das wird da finde ich zumindest schon mal recht angenehm geschrieben berufserfahrene
altiv fachleute sind bei uns genauso willkommen wie hochschulabsolventen mit überdurchschnittlichem
abschluss in informatik oder einer verwandten disziplin werkstätten können bei axo erste
industrie erfahrung sammeln erfahre selbst was es bedeutet ein axonaut zu sein ok ich
finde es ist irgendwie cool ja es klingt zwar lustig aber es hat hat irgendwo was es hat
irgendwo was so was axo bietet arbeit in einem professionell unkomplizierten team ok kollegen
mit vielseitigen kenntnissen und erfahrung und interessen partnerschaftliche vertrauensvolle
unternehmens das finde ich gut dass da partnerschaftlich steht das finde ich gut viele schreiben familiär
und das finde ich das geht mir voll auf den keks es muss nicht meine familie sein ich will
einfach nur arbeiten und gut ist partnerschaftlich vertrauensvoll und das finde ich klingt gut
partizipation am unternehmenserfolg mal gucken wie das was damit genau gemeint ist aber schon
mal nicht schlecht es kann natürlich auch bedeuten hey wir bezahlen dir nicht viel aber
wenn es mal gut läuft dann kannst du die kohle kriegen work life balance flexible arbeitszeiten
kleidzeit ok ja arbeiten in teilzeit möglichkeit zum home office ja das ist doch das finde
ich gut wenn man das gleich mal reinschreibt so muss das sein ich finde es gut dass teilzeit
prinzipiell direkt möglich ist und auch dass home office direkt möglich ist wahrscheinlich
100 prozent aber zumindest teilweise schaumparty besucher schreibt wenn die schon überdurchschnittliche
absolventen wollen dann hoffe ich mal die überdurchschnittlich bezahlen glaube ich
nicht das sieht wirklich ein bisschen mehr nach richtung richtung start up aus von der
benahmung her aber ich bin mir nicht sicher keine ahnung dann wird es nicht so sein aber
müssen wir uns können wir uns gleich mal angucken wer das eigentlich ist zeit für forschung
an eigenen themen das sind drei punkte finde ich absolut top ja sofern es nicht nur da
steht und auch gemacht wird betriebliche veraltersforscher kinderbetreuung auch super
und übrigens wisst ihr was ich was ich auch gut finde dass die dass die anfangen mit
einem relativ gut geschriebenen text und dann erst mal schreiben ja warum sollt ihr überhaupt
zu uns und nicht so wie alle anderen so nach dem motto 95 prozent so nach dem motto wir
sind die geilsten und ihr müsst 30 milliarden sachen können und dafür bekommt ihr nix das
finde ich so viel schöner gemacht jährliche unternehmenskonferenz legendäre events wie
sommerfest und weihnachtsfeier ok das ist das erste wovor ich mich persönlich drücken
würde großzügige weiterbildungsbudget konferenzsalam ja nicht schlecht vernünftige arbeitsmaterial
in gut ausgestatt das finde ich auch sinnvoll ist reinzuschreiben weil es schreiben fast
alle sowas wie ein ein moderner arbeitsplatz oder sowas steht bald bei total vielen stellenanzeigen
drin und auch bei total vielen stellenanzeigen die wir hier schon gesehen haben aber ein
moderner arbeitsplatz damit kann ja alles mit gemeint sein ich finde die vorteile kann
man schon hinschreiben vor allem wenn es wenn es notebooks gibt und sogar smartphones easy
elite richtig viele der anderen stellen beschreibungen da hast du das gefühl dass es so quasi eine
richtige ehre ist dort arbeiten zu dürfen hier klingt das tatsächlich zumindest wie
es geschrieben ist eher in die richtung das finde ich gut so darmstadt köln ok frankfurt
gibt es was gucken wir uns jetzt mal an cloud und der fox engineer dotnet core entwickler
oder was für mich in köln sogar gar nicht so weit weg it administrator ok die die zwei
sachen gucken wir uns jetzt mal an java experte exzellent dieser wir begeistern uns für neue
technologien ist die webseite eigentlich so dunkel wegen dem dark reader ich bin blind
leute ich muss erst mal wieder dunkel machen wir begeistern uns für neue technologien
effizienter wieder nach ausforderungen nichts verändert nichts verändert im moment unsere
arbeitswelt mehr als die fortschreitende digitale transformation dazu ah guck mal hier uns ist
nicht so wichtig dass du alle job voraussetzungen zu 100 prozent erfüllst sondern dass du
mit deinen stärken unseren team bereich das ist mal was hier so was so was normales habe
ich ja heute noch gar nicht gelesen das ist wenigstens mal da kannst du echt das gefühl
die sind noch normal im kopf nicht so wie manch andere sachen die wir heute schon gelesen
haben was macht die vm stimmt was macht die vm chrome ist immer noch nicht fertig aber
fast fast das chrome fertig ok das erwarte dich du begleitest die konzept wo sind wir
überhaupt cloud devops engineer du begleitest die konzeption entwicklung optimieren komplexe
innovativen software die stellen das so ein standardsatz du berätst zu cloud native architekturen
ok docker kubernetes du konzipierst und verantwortest die auslieferungsprozesse ja ok der software
beim kunden und stellst deren einhaltung sicher du ermitteln den ressourcen bedarf
zukünftiger systeme aus den fachlichen und technischen anfragen leitest daraus betriebskosten
ab denkt auch passend du bist verantwortlich für die konfiguration der entwicklungsumgebung
und laufzeit umgebung ok da ist mir jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig klar was damit gemeint
ist das klingt so ein bisschen nach so eine mischung aus server admin und rechenzentrums
mann du monitors die plattform des kunden und leitest daraus kontinuierlich das passt
auch für den devops engineer eins ganz gut ja das zeichnet sich aus du hast ein studium
mit vergleichbar qualifikation du hast erste erfahrung im betrieb von modernen virtuellen
laufzeit umgebung zum beispiel kontinuerisierung docker kubernetes helm cloud plattform gesammelt
ist gut wenn man ein cloud devops engineer sein will ja ich gehe mal auch easy light
ich wollte gerade was ähnliches sagen und zwar ich gehe auch mal davon aus dass das
nicht ein reiner personalmensch geschrieben hat das hat noch einen gewissen bezug zur
realität dieser stellenanzeige du bist immer daran interessiert die neuesten technologien
auszuwerten und passgenauen projekte einzubringen ok du hast ein ausgeprägtes analytisches
denkvermögen eine strukturierte sowie ergebnisorientierte arbeitsweise du bist ein team player verfügst
über ein offenes verbindliches auftreten du sprichst fließen deutsch mindestens c1 level
ich habe keine ahnung was c1 level ist aber wo wir gerade beim thema sind mein deutsch
ist halt anglizismen verseucht ich rede so eine zwischending aus deutsch englisch und
twitch emotes da müsste man neue sprache für erfinden glaube ich und mittlerweile
ist es so schlimm dass ich teilweise dass mir die sachen auf der arbeit auch schon raus
rutschen letztens erst wieder hat irgendeiner hat erzählt neue systeme sind da und ich
habe sowas geantwortet wie richtig pock und alle haben es gedacht pock pock pock pock
was und da habe ich mich für einen ganz kleinen moment ein bisschen fremd geschämt
aber dann war es mir auch wieder egal weil ich kann ja auch nichts dafür dass die leute
damit nichts anfangen können unser angebot an dich einsatz modernste technologien wie
etwa docker und kubernetes ok das ist sowohl anforderung als auch ein angebot zwölf weiter
bildungstage pro jahr verschulung das finde ich schön dass sie direkt schreiben so eine
hausnummer finde ich eigentlich nicht verkehrt anspruchsvoll und spannende projekte das wird
sich dann zeigen wenn man da ist teilnahme und austausch in unserer haus internen cloud
und def obs community keine festen arbeitszeiten keine stechung ist das überhaupt erlaubt
gab es da nicht erst letztens in urteil dass aber das zeit erfassung jetzt zwingend vorgeschrieben
ist ich bin kein also arbeitsrechtlich bin ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig bewandt aber
ich bilde mir ein es gab doch letztens irgendwie nen ja also das arbeitszeiten müssen erfasst
werden aber keine festen arbeitszeiten bedeutet ja auch nicht dass es keine arbeitszeit erfassung
gibt dass das kann gut und schlecht gleichermaßen sein ja keine festen arbeitszeiten also homeoffice
möglichkeit finde ich super dass das drin steht aber keine festen arbeitszeiten das
ist so eine sache also ich weiß gerne wann schluss ist ehrlich gesagt
faire umgang wertschätzung flache hier archiv und offene kommunikation auf augenhöhe
zuschussung von kindergaard das finde ich richtig cool richtig cool ich wollte ich wollte
es gut gut sagen dann habe ich mich zu cool um manche richtig cool finde ich das kita
plätze betriebliche altersvorsorge job tickets und sabbatical das ist glaube ich dass man
ein bisschen pause macht um sich was anderes zu kümmern moderne bureaus gute ausstatt höhenverstellt
sehr endlich schreibt das mal einer rein das sollten alle reinschreiben wenn sie das haben
das so muss das sein ja smartphone laptop was du sonst zum arbeitsraum in neuster ausstattung
legendäre event wie gesagt spieler gotte jeder wie er will für mich ist es nix ich will also
wie gesagt ich will nicht unbedingt dass die arbeit meiner familie ist und mehr familie ist
als meine echte familie und unsere eigene konferenz axokon solange das alles auf freiwilliger
basis ist und man kein schlechtes gewissen gemacht bekommt wenn man nicht mitmacht ist
das ja vollkommen in ordnung das ist ohne scheiß die beste stellenanzeige die man heute gelesen
haben was aber auch echt nicht schwer ist bei dem anderen krab IT admin ja wir gucken noch
mal schnell drüber du betreust unsere anwendung du übernimmst projekte in den first und second
level support noch mal first level support ich bin raus bruder muss los ich nein first
level support mein ne ne da raste ich aus was genau macht der first level support der
first level support kriegt anrufe wenn du wenn du einen server gemietet hast bei bei
strato oder bei hetzner und es geht was nicht und du rufst bei der hotline an dann ist die
chance dass du beim first level support rauskommst relativ hoch first level ist ist quasi schon
fast endkunden ist eigentlich endkundensupport ne das war ich first level support nein nein
da kriege ich da kratze ich ab nach einem halben jahr oder aber die verlieren so viele
kunden dass sie pleite gehen wenn die mich in first level support setzen wieviel verdient
man in dem bereich circa kann ich absolut nicht sagen keine ahnung das ist doch schön
also silence kills me ich muss sagen also ich hoffe ich habe jetzt nicht zu sehr gemeckert
ich neige ja dazu auch kleine sachen immer ein bisschen drüber drüber anzulästern
aber es ist die beste stellanzeige die wir heute gehabt haben der rest ist ja teilweise
echt abenteuerlich ja so und irgendjemand hat noch was vorgeschlagen gerade ja karriere.de
honeypot danke sehr interessant mal zuhören schön wenn es dir was gebracht hat liebe
bewerberin trotz der aktuellen situation rund um covid 19 sind wir natürlich okay klar
bleibt gesund exzellent wir sind gesund in der it branche im durchschnitt das kann man
auch nicht beantworten weil it branche ist so groß gefasst das kann was ich also mein
lieblingsbeispiel ist das geht los von jemand der weiß wie eine druckerpatrone tauscht
zu jemand der irgendwelche cloud projekte betreut oder sowas ja also das ist wirklich
ein riesen riesen spektrum und bandbreite was das sein kann also was ich ungefähr verdiene
hast ja hast ja vorher im stream vielleicht gesehen zumindest was im tarifvertrag steht
und ich mache sowas hier gerade und und ich glaube dass ich mich nach circa zehn jahren
in dem bereich durchaus auch senior nennen darf ja das stimmt pc lustig deutsche gehälter
sind allgemein ziemlich ziemlich gering also die gehälter in deutschland sind jetzt nicht
irgendwie riesig riesig groß ja und weiteres problem was wir halt in deutschland haben ist
dass der nicht der wohlstand das ist das falsche wort dass der das von vom geld was quasi da
so am start ist dass kaum was bei den leuten ankommt was auch ein problem was wir haben
also wenn man sich anguckt dass die schere zwischen arm und reich die letzten zehn jahre
glaube ich so schnell auseinandergegangen ist und so viel auseinandergegangen ist wie
nie vor vermögen genau vermögen genau das wort habe ich gesucht dass von der vom vermögen
an sich bei den leuten kaum was ankommt das ist in deutschland leider ist leider so also
die kombination aus viele abgaben viele steuern nicht allzu großen gehältern dazu kommt dass
die leute auch so gut wie nichts an an eigentum irgendwie haben deutschland ist ein niedrigsteuerland
ja wahrscheinlich wenn du ein großes unternehmen hast du nicht viel bezahlen musst an steuern
und abgaben bezahlen wir ziemlich viel und die leute haben ich glaube ich habe letztens
irgendeine statistik gesehen ich glaube 41 prozent 41 prozent haben in deutschland glaube
ich weniger als 10.000 euro oder dollar vermögen also weniger als 10.000 ist im prinzip fast
nichts das 41 prozent der leute leben mehr oder weniger wie sagt man so von der hand in
den mund von der von dem hand in dem löffel oder was auch immer also sprich 41 prozent
wenn ich wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz verkehrt liege in deutschland haben so gut wie nichts
an vermögen natürlich haben wir welche die extrem viel haben deswegen darf man ja auch
nicht den durchschnitt nehmen wo wir wieder bei der ursprünglichen frage sind die ich
da habe ich am letzten ein letztes stream schau was zu gesagt ich fand es halt ich fand
gerade bei dieser bei der ganzen corona geschichte wieder wieder offensichtlich dass die wahrnehmung
nicht so ganz mit der realität übereinstimmt nämlich vor corona haben ganz viele leute
erzählt uns geht es so extrem gut wir sind so wir wir damit ist ja quasi dann quasi im
durchschnitt jeder zweite ist ja dann quasi damit gemeint wir sind so reich uns geht so
gut und sonst was man wieder komplett ausgeklammert dass unser gesundheitssystem teilweise im arsch
ist die infrastruktur im arsch ist rennen erfandflaschen sammeln was auch immer ja
also wir auch schon mit sagen wir denen die am unteren ende der gesellschaft in deutschland
am start sind auch schon nicht allzu üppig haben aber alles wunderbar toll und dann
kommt corona fünf wochen corona auf einmal von wir haben so wahnsinnig viel geld und
und sind so ultra reich so scheiße wir sind pleite und da hat man wieder gesehen dass
die realität die die vorstellung im kopf nichts mit der realität zu tun hat wie kann
es sein von wir sind so ultra reich und alles ist geil in vier wochen auch scheiße wir sind
pleite ja wir wir also wenn du das über wenn du das gesamtvermögen irgendwie nimmst ja
dann sind wir reich aber wir ist nicht du nicht ja und das ist so eines das ist finde
ich mit das größte problem was wir in deutschland eigentlich haben dass der unterschied zwischen
arm und reich so extrem ist ich habe ich habe ja mal auf twitter sowas in der richtung
geschrieben und da kam gleich die ersten leute an max ich weiß gar nicht was du hast uns
geht es doch gut wir müssen nicht hungern und da denke ich mir so wie wir müssen nicht
hungern ist es also erstens würde ich das mal bezweifeln dass es nicht die ein oder
anderen leute gibt die tatsächlich hungern müssen wenn ich mir rentner angucke die fandflaschen
sammeln müssen aber ist es wirklich der anspruch den man hat an seine bevölkerung oder an den
wohlstand der bevölkerung ist es wirklich den anspruch den man als vier oder fünf größte
volkswirtschaft der welt hat dass die leute nicht hungern müssen wir sind wir sind doch
nicht in afrika da ist ok ja ich wäre froh wenn niemand auf der welt hungern müsste ja
aber man kann auch nicht sagen uns geht es gut solange wir nicht hungern müssen das
ist doch ein bescheuernes argument ich glaube wir sind die vier größte wirtschaft ich glaube
wir haben die vier größte vier oder fünf größte ich weiß es nicht genau aus dem kopf
wirtschaft der welt es gibt irgendwie die usa es gibt china es gibt japan und da kommen
entweder gleich wir oder es kommt noch irgendwie einer dazwischen so und ist es wirklich der
anspruch der vier oder fünf größten wirtschaft auf der welt dass die leute dass es ihnen
gut geht nur weil sie nicht hungern müssten indien keine ahnung ich weiß nicht was noch
dazwischen kommt aber wir sind ziemlich weit vorne ja was sucht man sucht man da russland
größte volkswirtschaft der welt ja europäische union die lassen wir jetzt mal weg da zählt
ja deutschland da zählt ja deutschland schon ordentlich mit dabei also china usa indien
japan deutschland also machen wir die europäische union weg dann sind wir auf dem fünften
platz oder sowas der big mac index vielleicht sind wir auch auf dem vierten platz ich bin
mir gar nicht mal so sicher also keine ahnung zumindest wir sind vier oder fünf größte
wirtschaft der welt also dazu sagen die leute müssen nicht hungern also da weiß ich nicht
was da was was da was da los ist ja wie bin ich jetzt wie bin ich jetzt zu dem ganzen
zu dem ganzen kram eigentlich gekommen ich weiß es nicht manchmal manchmal werde ich
von einfachen sachen ziemlich weit sei tracked hier auf statista sagen wir sind vierte ja
ich bilde mir auch an wir sind auf dem vierten platz ja und da hat man halt echt wieder gesehen
dass realität und vorstellung der leute im kopf überhaupt nicht zusammenpassen wie
gesagt innerhalb von vier fünf wochen so wir sind zu reich uns geht es gut alles toll
zu scheißen wir sind pleite weil dann die leute dann auch gemerkt haben wie gesagt unter
anderem 41 prozent die quasi von von paycheck zu paycheck leben die keinerlei vermögen
haben weil ich dann gemerkt habe scheiße wir haben kein geld mehr und das geht halt relativ
schnell dazu kommt dass die deutschen es nicht so gerne mögen quasi in eigenen häusern
zu leben die schweizer übrigens auch nicht habe ich gelesen schweizer auch nicht in
schweiz die schweiz baut wohl auch kaum einer häuser oder kauft wohl auch kaum einer häuser
aber in der schweiz verdienen die mehr in deutschland ist ja auch die frage in wie weit
es sich überhaupt lohnt in ein haus zu bauen ich meine haus kostet in deutschland unglaublich
viel geld du musst irgendwelche steuern bezahlen im zweifelsfall musst du noch straßensanierung
20.000 euro bezahlen also wahrscheinlich lohnt sich häuser kaufen in deutschland schlicht
nach greifen gar nicht in vielen anderen ländern ist das ist die ist die quote der leute die
im im eigenen haus oder zumindest in der eigenen wohnung wohnt viel viel höher ich weiß gar
nicht wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich auf den graben gekommen ist auch egal ich weiß nicht
mehr naja und und das zum abschluss zu sagen ich ich persönlich bin der meinung das größte
problem was wir in deutschland haben wo viele andere probleme ausgelöst werden ist tatsächlich
dass die spaltung zwischen arm und reich schon so groß ist und eher größer wird das führt
unter anderem dazu dass alle die eh schon so gut wie nichts haben gegeneinander ausgespielt
werden sei es jetzt der hat vier empfänger gegen den rentner gegen irgendwelche flüchtlinge
und und asylbewerber also sprich alle die eh schon nicht viel haben die sind jetzt auch
noch gegeneinander dann neidisch weil der andere 2 euro 30 mehr bekommt und das ist
einer der punkte die dadurch ausgelöst wird dass der unterschied zwischen arm und reich
in deutschland so riesengroß ist mittlerweile naja
es ist weltweites problem ja das das stimmt allerdings bei uns ist es extrem bei uns ist
es bei uns ist es wirklich es ist jetzt kein es ist jetzt kein witz bei uns ist es wirklich
extrem es gibt irgendwo einen report ich habe letztens ein video drüber geguckt ich
ich kriege das kriege das nicht mehr zusammen es gibt einen report der wird frag mich nicht
von ich müsste ich das video raussuchen erstellt das ist so eine zusammenfassung für banken
investoren alles möglich ist quasi so ein überblick so ein überblick report über
die jeweiligen länder wieder so die sitten sind und was so die unterschiedlichen länder
auszeichnet so und wisst ihr was bei deutschland in diesem report drinne steht unter anderem
das und das das wird bei deutschland hervorgehoben dass der unterschied zwischen arm und reich
und die verteilung quasi das was was an geld da ist und das was bei den leuten ankommt
ein großes ungleichgewicht hat und wenn so was in so einen report schon reinkommt dann
muss da auch irgendwas dran sein oder man kann ja auch nachgucken ich müsste ich müsste
das wie viel ich suche das video mal raus das können wir morgen oder so mal gucken
das ging nicht lang 15 minuten oder so das war echt gut gemacht und ich hatte auch den
eindruck dass es jemand ist der weiß wovon er redet ja das finde ich ist eines der größten
probleme wir haben und wo halt auch vieles draus resultiert und wir haben noch viele
andere probleme so ist es nicht ja es wird ja oftmals so getan als als haben wir haben
wir so viel geld uns geht so gut wir haben keine probleme stimmt ja nicht also guckt
euch mal an unsere info also ich will jetzt nicht wieder von internetausbau anfangen
ja also wir haben technisch den anschluss komplett verloren ich glaube irgendwie bei
irgendwelchen zukunftstechnologien sind wir bis auf vielleicht ein bisschen medizinische
sachen und vielleicht im bei autosachen wo sind wir sonst noch ganz gut dabei vielleicht
auch teilweise bei erneuerbaren energien wobei selbst da nicht solar panels kommen irgendwo
aus aus asien ist ja nicht so dass sie das von uns kommen also zukunftsmäßig haben wir
ziemlich den anschluss verloren bildung ja tatsächlich bildung wird lustigerweise bei
uns schlechter gemacht als sie ist ja das verstehe ich auch nicht unsere unsere bildung
der leute ist relativ gut also wir haben viele helle köpfe so ist es nicht und das ist in
deutschland tatsächlich nicht übel das wird es wird nicht gerade besser aber die das wird
als viel schlechter wahrgenommen als es irgendwie eigentlich eigentlich ist und dafür andere
sachen komischerweise als viel besser ja also wie gesagt irgendwie zukunftstechnologien
mäßig haben wir komplett den anschluss verloren muss ich noch mal unser internetausbau angucken
infrastruktur an sich sei es internetstraßen abwasser was auch immer ist teilweise sowas
von im arsch dass manche sachen überhaupt nicht mehr befahren sie befahrbar sind ja
es gibt es gibt so viel es gibt so viel sachen also wir haben genug wir haben genug sachen
wo es wirklich nicht vor vorzeigemäßig läuft die ausstattung in den schulen ist auch für
ein arsch ja was wir tatsächlich haben wo müssen wir jetzt auch bei dieser gelegenheit
mal erwähnen diese diskussionen die es gerade in den usa gibt gerade auch im polizei gewalt
und sowas gibt es bei uns zwar zum teil auch aber ich muss sagen mein persönlicher erfahrung
mit der polizei in deutschland war nicht schlecht und ich glaube dass das ein bereich ist wo
wir gerade im vergleich zu den usa wirklich gut dastehen auch was was unser system mit
gefängnissen angeht und mit der polizei das ist denke ich ziemlich gut bei uns hat die
polizei immer noch so das image so dein freund und helfer im endeffekt und usa ist eher
so hilf ich werde getasert wenn ich jetzt irgendwie doof schäpp gucke also das ist
bei uns schon deutlich besser man sieht ja auch die diskussion bei uns rennt einer mit
der ax durch den zug und wird erschossen was kommen bei uns für diskussion hätte der polizist
nicht besser zielen können dass er ihn nicht tödlich trifft ich bin ich persönlich bin
der meinung wenn jemand mit der ax durch den zug rennt oder mit dem messer und leute anpikst
dann muss er damit rechnen dass er erschossen wird ja vor allem wenn er mit der ax vielleicht
noch ein polizist zu rennen oder also natürlich kann man darüber diskutieren dass der polizist
hätte besser zielen sollen in usa wäre die diskussion schon komplett anders gewesen also
da sieht man dass unsere polizei nicht nicht schlecht ist und das finde ich unser weg in
der richtung auch nicht verkehrt ist also mir ist die deutsche polizei um 1000 mal lieber
als in usa ich hätte überhaupt keine bedenken zur polizei zu gehen wenn irgendwas ist in
usa würde ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich zweimal überlegen true elmo weiß ich nicht ob das
wirklich so ist es wird ja alle sachen die um rand erscheinen wo es um rand erscheinungen
geht wird ja dank social media und teilweise auch berichterstattung oftmals maßlos übertrieben
da hast du das gefühl quasi es gibt nur noch extreme obwohl das gar nicht so ist was was
allerdings der fall ist es gibt wirklich immer weniger leute habe ich zumindest den eindruck
die die welt eben nicht schwarz und weiß sehen sondern den die sich auch mal gedanken machen
dass es durchaus möglich ist dass auch jemand den man nicht mag sinnvolle sachen erzählen
kann
es wird teilweise echt übertrieben also ich glaube ich glaube nicht dass so viele leute
extrem sind in irgendeiner ausprägung natürlich gibt es die und ich würde mal bezweifeln
ob es wirklich so ist dass bei der polizei so viel rechtsextreme sind es sind halt gerade
die beispiele die rauskommen also wie gesagt ich habe von unserer polizei bisher nur super
erfahrung gemacht ja klar ich bin ein weißer alter heterosexueller mann das ist ja so die
gruppe den angeblich nie was passiert und boomer naja ich bin 35 und ich esse auch noch
fleisch de facto omni vor habe ich noch vergessen weißer heterosexueller alter omni vor mann
jetzt ja vorbei jetzt kann ich kann mich eigentlich gleich aus dem fenster stürzen
das ist verwirkt da kann ich mich nicht überblicken lassen ich könnte ja wenigstens schwul sein
oder so aber nein ich bin wirklich voll 0815 was das angeht so privilegiert ja ich weiß
ich darf dazu eigentlich gar nichts sagen aber das schöne ist dass ich trotzdem dazu
was sagen darf uns keiner verbieten kann und das ist auch ein punkt was ich persönlich
für recht wichtig halte ist dass man ein bisschen weniger auf so pauschalen sachen
rumreitet ja kaum sagt einer irgendwas kontroverses ist er entweder ein nazi ein verschwörungstheoretiker
nicht mehr ganz dicht oder sonst irgendwas also ich finde das immer ein bisschen schnell
ich finde das sind wir ein bisschen viel leute ein bisschen übereilig so nach dem motto
einer sagt was was war was nicht so ganz konform ist was nicht so ganz passt und schon ist
er ein eines der verschwörungstheorie leute oder irgendwas wo man ja eh nichts drauf geben
muss was was sich solche leute nicht überlegen ist dass gerade diese einstellung dazu führt
dass die leute extremer werden als sie eigentlich sind das ist ja grad der witz dran wenn jemand
nicht extrem ist aber vielleicht eine kontroverse meinung zu einem thema hat ja selbst allerdings
nie diese meinung mit gewalt durchsetzen würde und das ist ja das was was er letztendlich
extremer auszeichnet ja es gibt jemand der eine kontroverse meinung würde aber nie im
traum dran denken diese meinung irgendwie mit gewalt durchzusetzen oder irgendwie gewalttätig
zu werden was meint ihr macht das mit den leuten wenn der sich von allen seiten permanent
anhören muss was für ein vollspast er ist dass er verschwörungstheoretiker ist dass
er nazi ist dass er sonst was und sonst was ist das wird über kurz oder lang dazu führen
dass derjenige der nicht wirklich extrem war vielleicht eine kontroverse meinung hatte
irgendwann durchaus mal extrem werden kann und das ist glaube ich das was ich viele leute
mal überlegen müssen dass so dieses pauschale dieses pauschale in irgendeine ecke stellen
so nach dem motto deine meinung ist es gar nicht wert darüber zu sprechen dass das gerade
dazu führt dass nicht leute weniger extrem werden sondern dass mehr leute extrem werden
die können meinetwegen können die alle ihren bullshit erzählen ich habe kein problem mit
wenn flachertler erzählen dass die erde flach ist ja da müssen sie aber auch damit klar
kommen wenn ich sage ja ok kannst du mir erklären warum ich die sonne wieder sehe wenn ich mit
einer drohne am strand hoch fliege den meisten werden dann schon stinkig oder so es kann
mir auch meinetwegen jemand erzählen dass obamas bodyguard ein exen mensch ist es was
was juckt es mich es kann auch jemand sagen 5g verursacht korona oder oder sonst was ja
die können die können auch viel erzählen wenn der tag lang ist was juckt es mich denn
ich will jetzt nicht von den üblichen sachen anfangen weil das wieder weil das wieder viele
diskussionen im chat aus li auf auslöst ja aber man kann die leute durchaus zu wort
kommen lassen ich finde da ist überhaupt nichts verwerfliches dran und man sollte weniger
man sollte weniger pauschalen mitverschwörungstheorie und und so was die sachen abhandeln weil
wie gesagt auch wenn wenn man jemand überhaupt nicht ab kann bedeutet das nicht automatisch
dass er nur schwachsinn erzählt also selbst wenn ich jemand überhaupt nicht mag und
er schon immer bullshit erzählt hat wie sagt man so schön blindes hun findet auch mal
ein korn können auch leute die viel bullshit erzählen ab und zu mal sinnvolle sachen erzählen
sie bringt man denn 5g mit korona in verbindung ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht die bringen
korona mit 5g in verbindung weil in wuhan wofür korona ausgebrochen ist der 5g ausbau
relativ weit fortgeschritten ist und weil es leute gibt die sagen 5g strahlung würde
also ist quasi die hat so eine hohe frequenz was sie im endeffekt ja nicht hat aber die
hat so eine hohe frequenz dass sie das erbgut von zellen verändern kann und deswegen korona
ergibt aus wissenschaftlicher sicht überhaupt keinen sinn
deswegen finde ich wichtig man sollte durchaus alle zu wort kommen lassen es ist es kann
kein es kann keine lösung sein letztendlich dass man diskussion unterbindet und verbietet
ja weil gerade das führt dazu dass unter anderem was gerade von verschwörungstheorien
hatten dass verschwörungstheorien auf auf irgendwie fruchtbaren boden fallen wenn es
wenn es gewisse themengebiete gibt oder vielleicht auch dass leute extrem werden in der ein oder
anderen richtung wenn gewisse themengebiete absolutes tabu sind nie besprochen werden
und quasi den leute mehr oder weniger der mund verboten wird dazu was zu sagen natürlich
finden die sich dann irgendwie zusammen in kröpfchen und überlegen sich nicht ob obamas
bodyguard nicht doch ein exenmensch war das sorgt also nicht diskutieren oder nicht ansprechen
sorgt gerade dafür dass solche sachen sich verbreiten naja gut was auch immer lang rum
gelabert zur lagi der nation so sehe ich das so ich wollte übrigens heute noch warzone
spielen allerdings nicht im stream mal gucken ob chrome fertig kompiliert ist chrome ist
fertig kompiliert excellent es hat funktioniert jetzt guck mal wo ist er denn wo ist mein
fertig kompilierter chrome wo liegt er denn bin aus wo ist mein fertig kompilierter chrome
also ich bin ich bin gut
da ist er bamm crow oh
naja ok was muss man sonst noch machen how to compile chrome wo hatten wir es denn hier
run chrome nee ah ich bin im container genau haha ich hab doch kein xserver hier im container
kann ich jetzt nicht einfach den kram auf meinem host starten das müssen wir mal ausprobieren
war lip lx moment wo wo wo speichert der kram denn machines
wo liegt lx serum war snap lxd wo liegen meine container war wo liegen meine container rum
wo liegen dann meine container rum
gute frage wo liegen die denn also ich meine chrome liegt hier chrome default location
pool false search pool wo liegt er denn
vielleicht data hallo informatiker underscore hier war snap lxd discs scheiße ok discs containers
ah ah da sind wir root home nicht home root was wird heute gemacht wir haben uns gerade
nur ein paar stellenanzeigen angeguckt nachdem wir mit allen fertig waren ich habe allerdings
gestern chrome selbst kompiliert und der ist jetzt fertig ich wollte gerade mal gucken ob
der funktioniert rom source out default rom
ah da war er hab den gesehen ganz kurz war er da aber er crashed mein selbst kompilierter
chrome crashed feels bad man vier stunden kompiliert und jetzt geht er nicht mal mehr
f press f vor chrome schade dass das nicht funktioniert ok wir starten es einfach mal
als normaler user wir starten das mal als normaler user ah permission denied ok ich
sieh du wir starten wir starten das mal als normaler user cd chrome source out default so und das
kopieren wir jetzt einfach mal wie groß ist denn das eigentlich wie groß ist in der ordner
eigentlich zwölf gigabyte wtf wir starten das mal als normaler user erstmal stoppen
erstmal den container stoppen wtf zwölf dann move ich das einfach move das da nach home
test ne home max zack achso bin ja schon im richtigen verzeichnis default nach home max
haben wir hier den default default und für mein user ok und jetzt können wir hier mal
chrome starten und gucken ob es funktioniert chrome mein selbst kompilierter chrome funktioniert
excellent leute so sieht so siehts aus chrome selbst kompiliert und er funktioniert wer
mich jetzt wer jetzt fragt was es bringt der hat den sinn nicht verstanden bringen tut
das nämlich gar nix bringt doch doch das stimmt nicht es bringt was es bringt erstens man hat
ahnung wie es geht und zweitens wenn man mal in den chrome custom patches bauen will
hat man schon mal ahnung wie man das machen kann funktioniert nice sehr schön allerdings
habe ich so ziemlich es heißt chrome es ist es ist nur die nur der chromium anteil es
ist nur der chromium anteil geht auch auf windows basis ja geht auch allerdings hat
halt ist hier glaube ich wir haben ja sehr viel abgeschaltet und dementsprechend ein
bisschen ruckelig ist das ganze also ich glaube so ziemlich hier ist so ziemlich keinerlei
beschleunigung drin und ich vermute mal dass wir sogar ein debug bild haben weil das ist
so krass langsam der chrome im vergleich zum normalen chrome das guck mal hier normales
ding überhaupt kein problem das übrigens firefox normaler chrome versus ja ja stimme zu normaler
chrome versus mein selbst kompilierter chrome ist es sind halt welten dazwischen guck mal
youtube komm mal hier die geschwindigkeit ist nicht zu über der unterschied ist nicht zu
übersehen ok jetzt hängt meiner mein mein anderer chrome ein bisschen aber
warum bist du so langsam gerade chrome weil mein anderer browser 100 prozent cpu last verursacht
exzellent guckt euch das ist ein chrome debug bild 100 pro so so langsam wie das ist ich glaube
wir hätten die option setzen müssen dass wir kein debug bild machen das ist ganz schön ganz schön
lahm cancel was naja wie dem auch sei wir haben tatsächlich es geschafft ein chrome selbst zu
kompilieren und er funktioniert damit bin ich zufrieden wunderbar exzellent was wo ist der
unterschied zwischen swap mit hibernator und und swap ohne hibernator ist eigentlich so
ein sleep modus wo dein computer strom spart mit swap oder ohne da weiß ich jetzt grad nicht was
du meinst also ich gehe ziemlich stark davon aus dass es ein debug bild ist weil so langsam
wie das ist im vergleich zum anderen chrome guckt euch mal wenn ich den den den fertig
fertig gebauten vom betriebssystem verwende chrome ihr seht den geschwindigkeitsunterschied
oder ich glaube ihr seht den geschwindigkeitsunterschied es ist einfach da und geht ich hätte
wahrscheinlich den release bild machen müssen wirklich wir wollten uns hier den kram noch
angucken den jemand im chat gepostet hat die stellenanzeige hier von hypoport
muss mal kurz gucken ob ich nicht was im chat übersehen hab nicht so aus und eben
bei gucken nicht dass ich passapst übersehen hab any primers steamlabs
bei sehr ganz gerne mal zwischendurch sachen aus versehen ja war ich ja nicht absichtlich
rick 535 resub zwei monate habe ich nicht gesehen dankeschön für den sub excellent
subscription dankeschön pock massif huge pock du meinst das hier bei manjaro installer moment
ich gucke es mir mal kurz an erase disc no swap ich glaube ich weiß was der meint das
sind zwei sachen hier legt er gar keine swap partition an hier legt er eine swap partition
an und hier legt er eine swap partition an mit der möglichkeit dass du hibernate machen
kannst was mit dem swap nichts zu tun hat wenn ich jetzt nicht komplett falsch liege hibernate
ist dass du quasi den ram inhalt auf die festplatte schreibst und der rechner ausgeht
und dann den ram inhalt beim booten von der festplatte liest und dann quasi wieder an
der stelle bist du rechner ausgeschaltet hast ich glaube die sachen haben gar nichts
zu richtig miteinander zu tun ruhe zustand genau ruhe zustand
aber wenn du in der vm unterwegs bist ist das eh egal hibernate brauchst du in der
vm nicht vms kannst du ja einfach easy as fuck anhalten jetzt zack so vm angehalten
kannst nächstes mal an der stelle weitermachen hibernate ohne swap geht nicht beziehungsweise
macht keinen sinn ist das so ja klar ergibt keinen sinn hast du recht du musst ja irgendwo
den ram inhalt hinschreiben und das einfachste ist schon den bestehenden swap auf die platte
zu schreiben ja ergibt sinn so also jetzt wollten wir uns das hier noch angucken ich
weiß nicht mehr wer gepostet hat ich hoffe er ist noch da wenn ich gucke ich mir trotzdem
an also hypoport komplexität simplicität auch richtiger zungenbrecher er modernisiere
mit uns eine ganze ganze industrie natürlich auf dem sofa mit dem macbook was sonst ok
senior devops cloud engineer im fintech bist du entwickler und hast ein steckenpferd operations
entdeckt wahrscheinlich hat man den satz gemacht weil es halt der fobs heißt hast
du spaß am entwickeln und betreiben von modernen einfachen lösungen wer hat daran
kein spaß perfekt wir kümmern uns um das privat kreditangebot der europäische plattform
vom frontend über apx blablabla ok also wir sehen deine aufgaben bei uns aus du entwickelst
unsere service infrastruktur weiter so unterstützt uns beim betrieb unser bestehenden virtualisierten
linux server und der darauf laufende infrastruktur klingt ein bisschen nach vmw
dabei legst du ein besonderes augenmerk auf die aktualität sicherheit und verfügbarkeit
unserer datenbanken sowie zuverlässige backups container orchestration gehört für dich dabei
zum alltag es kann prinzipiell alles sein ja aber wenn man hier von im enterprise business
bereich ist es halt nun mal oft vmw wenn man von wenn man von eigener hardware ausgeht
ja und ansonsten was unter azure beziehungsweise google drunter ist kann uns ja egal sein du
bringst uns in die clout du bringst ein umfangreicher und praktische erfahrungen mit cloud provider
wie aws oder warum will keine azure ich kenne mich nur mit google und azure aus von aws
habe ich keinen plan aber das ist kein ding also die zaubern hier alle nicht wenn man
ein bisschen ahnung von azure und google hat muss man sich an das andere interface gewöhnen
und ich denke aber da kommt man mit aws auch ganz gut klar treibe das thema und überlege
mit uns wann wie und in welchem umfang wir mit unseren services in die cloud gehen neben
der reinen umsetzung hast du dafür datenschutz datensicher das große ganze wird zu oft gar
nicht dran gedacht das ist gut dass das hier drin steht was allerdings der chat meinte
gerade ja dann sieht man doch was damit oben gemeint ist ne sieht man nicht da steht nur
du unterstützt uns beim betrieb unserer bestehenden virtualisierten dealung server es kann durchaus
sein dass diese server noch bei ihnen lokal laufen und dann ist es höchstwahrscheinlich
vor mwr was würdest du zu azure versus google cloud sagen azure also azure ist zwar auch
undurchsichtig und bei azure kostet auch alles jeder klick gefühlt irgendwas ja sogar wusste
dir dass es in azure was kostet wenn du die admin konsole aufmachst das ist kein witz
wenn ihr die azure die azure admin konsole das erste mal startet kostet das geld weil
ein bisschen weil er einen storage container unten drunter braucht oder einen storage ich
weiß pool heißt ich glaube ich in dem fall und das kostgeld und die bedienung von der
google cloud ist finde ich ziemlich pains jam da blicke ich auch nicht richtig durch
immer wo was ist also ich finde so wie die azure oberfläche auch ist sie ist noch die
beste krasius schreibt wollte meinen kleinen vps auf azure aufteilen aber das ist ja das
ist teuer das lohnt sich nicht also so richtig so richtig lohnen tut sich diese ganze cloud
geschichte bei azure oder auch bei google cloud eigentlich nur dann wenn man keine vm
haben will sondern wenn man halt eben wirklich cloud services verwendet sei es die kosmos
db geschichte bei azure oder irgendwelche functionen sachen halt wenn man wirklich nicht
die alte technik einfach nur in die cloud verlagert sondern neue technik verwendet
dann kann das was heißt dann lohnt sich das dann kann sich das lohnen und auch nur wenn
man von den vorteilen profitiert also sprich wenn du sagst ja ich brauche die fette anbindung
ja ich brauche die hochverfügbarkeitsgeschichten und sowas dann kann sich das lohnen wenn
du einfach nur irgendwo eine vm gemietet hast wo eine web anwendung für 10 benutzer drauf
läuft ja dann kann man sich das mit azure auch sparen also wir haben es aktuell so wie
gesagt ich habe ja so ein kleines projekt mit einem kollegen gerade am start wir machen
es so wir haben bei hetzner jetzt eine kiste mit ssd und glaub vier kern oder so das eines
der kleinsten sachen die es gibt funktioniert ganz gut und einmal im monat miete ich mir
für ein paar stunden bei digital ocean aber wahrscheinlich mache ich in zukunft dann
auch bei hetzner vorher waren wir auch nicht bei hetzner wir sind erst bei hetzner seit
dem wir preise verglichen haben und hetzner ist echt gut und günstig miete ich mir eine
vm mit 96 kern und 128 gigabyte ram macht da unser open street view routing preprocessing
und dann lösche ich die vm wieder das kostet dann drei euro dafür lohnt sich aber ich
würde nie auf die idee kommen dass wir unser unser zeug da irgendwie in azure betreiben
als vm oder so das das lohnt sich nicht doch es gibt eine sache da lohnt sich da lohnt
sich tatsächlich wenn man im gratis budget bleibt dann lohnt sich zum beispiel wenn man
sich bei google registriert und vor hat man möchte google maps oder so api geschichten
von google verwenden hat man glaube ich 200 oder 300 dollar im monat quasi mit drinne
und das lohnt sich dann allerdings wird schnell relativ teuer wenn man über dieses frei budget
rüber geht firebase habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert ich ja aber easy light du hast recht also
ich würde prinzipiell immer gucken wenn ich sowas hausen möchte projekt habe wie weit
ich mit irgendwelchen free tiers komme oftmals ziemlich weit zumindest für den anfangen
ich meine es hausen nicht jeder twitter oder facebook ja die die die also die die kostenlose
monats sache sachen sind bei allen cloud anbietern relativ hoch weil die wollen ja leute gewinnen
allerdings bei google bietet sich an weil es nichts vergleichbares zu google maps gibt
in der in dem umfang ja also gerade die adressvervollständigung ist wirklich das beste ich habe einige sachen
verglichen ja von kostenlosen sachen auf street view basis bis map box bis bing und
alles das beste was es gibt für adress suche und adressvervollständigung ist google maps
ich habe nichts gefunden was ansatzweise da dran kommt google maps frisst alle möglichen
kombinationen von von straße und postleitzahl zu ohne postleitzahl mit ortsname von verschriebenem
ortsname zu nur unvollständig eingetragener straße mit hausnummer google maps frisst
alles und vervollständigen alles besser als der rest also ich habe nichts gefunden was
ähnlich gut ist wie die ganze wie die autocompletion und die adress suche bei google maps ein open
street maps ist super für die map allerdings die anderen services sind meilenweit hinter
dem was google oder oder map box auch anbietet die das open street maps routing was es gibt
gibt es einen open source projekt für open street maps routing das ist wiederum ganz
gut das verwenden wir zur routenberechnung weil es kostenlos ist weil da sind wir wieder
an dem punkt wo google services wieder ziemlich teuer werden würden man muss halt schauen
wie man es macht das ist von projekt zu projekt unterschiedlich und auch von anwendungsgebiet
zur anwendung krafthopper krafthopper habe ich auch ausprobiert krafthopper war nicht
alles richtig also krafthopper habe ich versucht bei der autover vollständigung glaube ich
oder war es beim routing ich weiß nicht war nicht so schön ne was wir jetzt verwenden
ne ne ja doch kann ich kann ich zeigen wie ist das ja das verwenden wir
das kannst du selber hosten ja du kannst die routing also du kannst das projekt was
die routen berechnet kannst du selber hosten und dazu dass es die routen berechnen kann
musst du natürlich noch hier musst du dir noch ne musst du zum beispiel sowas noch parallel
betreiben das ist nämlich die datenbank mit routing information von open street maps
so rest musst du selbst rausfinden weil ich verrat ja nicht unser unsere geschäftsidee
hier oder was wir da genau machen im hintergrund krafthopper ist ist preprocessed ja ich preprocesse
selber deswegen brauche ich ja einmal im monat keine ahnung 64 48 kerne 96 gigabyte ram vm
was ist eigentlich docker ok ich versuche das mal so kurz wie möglich zu beantworten
was docker ist docker ist ein frontend eigentlich hauptsächlich ein kommando zeilen tool mit
dem du gesendbox linux anwendung starten kannst so das war jetzt die kurz die kürzeste
fassung die geht ohne irgendwelche spezifischen begriffe zu verwenden docker ist aber keine
vm habe ich auch nicht gesagt das war schon sehr it deutsch es ist auch ganz schön schwierig
docker ohne it sachen zu erklären ok anstatt sendbox könnte man ab könnte man gekapselte
anwendungen nehmen oder sowas ok es ist es ist ok frontend frontend es ist eine benutzer
schnitt stelle die dir ermöglicht besonders abgekapselte linux anwendung zu starten war
das jetzt besser chat keinerlei keinerlei englische anglizismen und zeug drin war auch
nicht besser wer interessiert docker unter windows docker ist eigentlich so eine der
ursprünglichen frontends für linux container einer der ersten nicht nicht die erste ich
glaube lxc die die das lxc frontend also das problem ist in linux heißt vieles lxc aber
das das frontend lxc frontend war noch glaube ich ein bisschen vorher vorher aber docker
war eines der ersten und docker war mit das produkt was diesen ganzen linux container
hype ausgelöst hat leider wurden dann container zumindest am anfangen wo man noch für alles
docker verwendet hat immer weiter zweck entfremdet von quasi einer hilfe für entwickler dass
sie ihre software einfacher bauen können oder dass man mal kleine sachen ausprobiert
wurden dann übers knie gebrochen irgendwelche produktions die pläumen strategien aus den
fingern gesaugt die mehr schlecht als recht funktioniert haben und man hat ein bisschen
aus den augen verloren für was docker eigentlich ursprünglich mal gedacht war für die für
diese anwendungszwecke gibt es mittlerweile andere tools unter anderem kubernetes was
er gerade voll angesagt ist aber docker ist immer noch für ich möchte mal was kleines
bei mir ausprobieren auf der linux kiste das tool der wahl es gibt ein paar alternative
implementierungen weil man das unter linux ja ganz gerne macht dass es für alles 50
verschiedene sachen gibt aber docker wird noch lange in begriff sein so also wir wollten
mal die stellanzeige kurz fertig angucken wie sehen deine aufgaben bei uns entwickelt unsere
infrastruktur weiter das hatten wir schon du bringst uns die cloud hatten wir auch schon
du optimierst die operationalen aspekte unserer services also quasi admin geschichten oder
du schreckst nicht vor weiterentwicklung unserer spring java common bra weiche java schüttet
den kaffee aus was erwarten wir von dir fauleheit excellent endlich mal einer der es kapiert
faule programmierer und faule admins ist das beste was man bekommen kann das kapiert so
irgendwie keiner faule programmierer und faule admins ist das beste was es gibt weil was
die machen das funktioniert direkt mal wir haben ja java true elmo das liegt daran das
java gerade so im bank und versicherungsumfeld halt das ding ist schlechthin im back end
da sind nicht nur 80 prozent aller software entwickler java entwickler 80 prozent aller
software ist auch in java ein bisschen front end html css kommt dabei und für die richtig
hardcore sachen kommt ein ibm mainframe mit kobold an start dann ist eh vorbei 80 prozent
java 20 prozent kobold und du hast quasi die back end infrastruktur von so einer bank
am start übrigens ich habe letztes mal im chef gesagt fällt mir gerade ein das müssen
wir echt auch mal im stream machen ich habe letztes mal im chef gesagt ich würde mal
wieder gerne ein bisschen mehr sachen selbst programmieren und und habe ich ihm vorgeschlagen
ja wir können es doch so machen moment stream ideen da habe ich ihm vorgeschlagen wir können
es doch so machen dass ich ihm mal eine skillliste schicke somit sachen die ich also sprachen
und frameworks wo ich mich gut mit auskenne und er kann ja mal gucken oder er wird mal
gucken meinte er was was wir da für möglichkeiten haben okay schicke ich dir mal das können
wir echt mal im stream machen da kann ich mir mal aus den fingern saugen von was ich
ein bisschen ahnung habe und von was nicht ja er wird mal gucken in form von wir machen
ja relativ viel cloud geschichten aktuell da ist halt go recht angesagt also gerade
was was was azure und automatisierung sachen angeht und ich habe den fehler gemacht ich
habe gesagt ich kann auch ein bisschen java programmieren das hatten gleich auf den plan
gerufen festgestellt wir haben noch so ein paar kacke java anwendungen wo wir was dran
machen müssen habe ich aber gleich gesagt ich kann zwar ein bisschen java programmieren
aber ich will ja aber programmieren das werde ich das werde ich dann auch auf die skillliste
schreiben aber als als negativ skill danach dem motto dass ich kann zwar java programmieren
aber ich muss mir etwas schlimmes einfallen lassen warum er mich nicht java programmieren
lassen sollte okay was haben wir hier sonst noch faulheit also ich finde super dass es
mal einer reinschreibt ja faulheit ist faule admins faule software entwickler ist das das
beste was man haben kann die sachen funktionieren was sie machen best und worst practices das
du hast schon einiges erlebt und bringst deine expertise und erfahrung als entwickler auch
beim lösen und automatisieren von operationalen themen ein könnte man nicht sagen bei administrativen
themen ich finde operationalen themen klingt so so so irgendwie wie ein wort was man sonst
nie verwendet ich finde administrativen themen klingt irgendwie passender auch wenn es es
vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig trifft was gemeint ist können zumindest die leute
dies lesen glaube ich mehr mit anfangen einfachheit du strebst nach einfachen übersicht den lösungen
dabei helfen in deine bereits gesammelten berufliche erfahrung und dein interesse
an obsorz das ist das wirklich was für mich hier du machst Dinge nicht einfach nur anders
weil du es immer so gemacht hast stattdessen versuchst du die hintergründe zu verstehen
nutzt dieses wissen um zu einer pragmatischen lösung zu kommen ja das wird viel zu oft
vernachlässigt man sollte das nehmen was für die sache am besten funktioniert fertig
na wenn ich die auswahl habe zwischen unterschiedlichen technologien die sich alle halbwegs gut einigen
klar dann nehme ich das was ich am liebsten mag aber ich muss jetzt nicht ihr wisst ich
programmieren gerne sie scharf und ich mag als web anwendung speckend auch unglaublich
gerne asp.net core aber ich würde nicht auf die idee kommen wenn ich irgendwie das nehmen
wir mal was was können wir machen ja wenn ich irgendwie auf dem linux system alle fünf
minuten was laufen lassen will da würde ich keine dotnet core anwendung machen da würde
ich drei zeilen bash machen und ein grondjob also man muss das nehmen was passt dass das
sage ich auch immer und es wird viel zu oft irgendwas genommen einfach nur weil sie leute
geil finden und es ist genauso bei neuen halbgeschichten damals als noch ges neu war und mongo db war
neu vielleicht kann sich der eine oder andere auch dran erinnern wie viele projekte haben
hirnlos ohne das zu hinterfragen angefangen wir machen jetzt noch ges und mongo db jetzt
sind wir voll in der zukunft und unsere software auf einschlag richtig gut anstatt sich vorher
mal gedanken zu machen und haben sie nachher festgestellt scheiße eine relationale datenbank
wäre vielleicht doch besser gewesen und wir wollen eigentlich ziemlich viel multithreading
machen na da war mongo db und noch ist doch keine so gute idee also man muss immer das
nehmen was gut passt wenn es mehrere sachen gibt die gut passen dann kann man sich ja
das aussuchen was einem besten gefällt wird viel zu wenig gemacht finde ich gut dass sie
reingeschrieben haben überblick dir fällt es leicht einen schritt zurück zu machen
und zu hinterfragen ob dinge zielführenden sieht ohne das ziel aus den augen zu verlieren
auch nicht verkehrt ja wenn es um sachen geht du machst dinge nicht einfach nur anders
weil du es immer so gemacht hast gibt eine sache die mache ich immer so und das ist meckern
über c++ weil c++ die hässlichste und ekligste programmiersprache ist die es gibt da prokramiere
ich lieber was im brainfuck ok das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben aber
aber c++ ist einfach nur pains jam pur ok also was haben wir als nächstes kommunikationsstarker
teamplayer du bist mit herz und sehne teamplayer du formulierst klar und verständlich bis
zu dem offen und durchsetzung stark klar und verständlich kann ich sachen leider nur formulieren
wenn meine gegenstelle twitch emotes versteht also wenn mich jemand fragt so nach dem motto
wie findest du java und ich sage feels badman oder pippenhans oder pains champ oder versteht
mich dann ist das klar und verständlich formuliert wenn er das nicht versteht dann liegt sie
ja nicht an mir da kann ich ja nichts dafür dass das ja quasi dass seine allgemeinbildung
so große lücken aufweist dass er die gängigsten banner twitch tv emotes nicht versteht wenn
er mir antwort verstehe keckw dann weiß ich was los ist dann weiß ich hab mich verstanden
teams braucht unbedingt custom emotes krasius gebe ich dir recht custom emotes sind ein
absolutes muss sogar sogar whatsapp kann custom emotes warum kann teams das nicht also wenn
whatsapp schon irgendwas kann dann muss das teams auch kann whatsapp whatsapp ist auch
so eine pains champ anwendung
stehen wir mal vor du sagst dann kappa oder nimmt es ernst ja deswegen ich also eine sache
die mir ja in den ganzen ich weiß es sind sticker in whatsapp habe ich heute auch gelernt
ich wusste gar nicht dass das geht bis heute morgen was ich ja erwarte ist noch in stellen
in stellen an an anzeigen das als was wir was wir was wir erwarten das drin steht kenntnis
der gängigen twitch emotes also wenn ich eine eigene firma hätte und leute suchen würde
wäre das das erste was drin steht kenntnis der gängigen twitch emotes nicht etwa kenntnis
der gängigen versionsverwaltungstools oder sowas kenntnis der gängigen twitch emotes
das wäre das allerwichtigste dass man sich auch auf augenhöhe unterhalten kann wie man
so schön sagt was hältst du von richards dollman weder noch er hat schon bisschen
bisschen ja bisschen man kann es nicht radikale einstellung nennen aber ein bisschen gefestigte
einstellung zu manchen themen er ist ja zum beispiel auch ganz stinkig wenn man einfach
nur linux sagt und nicht knu linux wupplox gmbh wäre super was hast du für produkte
ja wie gesagt eine web anwendung mit der du als handwerker die optimale route zu deinen
kunden berechnen kannst mehr haben wir noch nicht und die ist auch noch beta und noch
gar nicht fertig oh nee hör mal auf nein nein please leute nicht diese copypasta nicht
diese copypasta ok ihr wollt ihr wolltet es leute jetzt wirst
von den virgin check machen wenn wir gerade mal copypasta spam sind oh miss ich bin als
ja selbst pokis ab oh fuck der true morpheus ich habe mir den namen sogar gemerkt hat
mir einen pokis abgegiftet oh je ich bin nicht safe leute jungfrau confirmed jetzt ist vorbei
gegiftet klar ist nur ausrede ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß es ist wahrscheinlich mein
zweiter account ja schon klar schon klar so schnell kann es gehen
es war gegiftet aber selbst wenn ich ja man muss sich nicht dafür schämen wenn man subscribt
hat auf twitch habt ihr euch schon mal überlegt ob ihr nicht vielleicht den wupplox subscriben
wollt weil ihr bekommt dann immerhin sagenhafte vier emotes und absoluten high iq durch den
chat und demnächst hoffentlich weitere emotes ich mein wir haben noch 16 emotes slots frei
ich kümmere mich drum leute ich kümmere mich drum
ich habe vorhin im youtube video gesehen dass bei dir glaube ich die ads im video automatisch
geskippt wurden ne das habe ich von hand gemacht aber es gibt einen addon was das macht
ich habe vergessen wie das heißt das hat man hier im chat einer empfohlen es gibt es gibt
so ein add skipper so ein add skipper plugin für youtube
ne das meine ich nicht ich weiß nicht mehr wie es heißt ok nochmal schnell hier durchlesen
was sie sonst noch haben wollen
allerdings gibt es bei diesem add skipper plugin ja nicht um ads von youtube zu skippen sondern
um embedded apps also wenn linus in seinen videos etwas zu einem tollen hardware anbieter
erzählt das gibt es addons die können das skippen das geht natürlich nur mit community
hilfe denke ich mal wenn die quasi reporten von wo bis wo die werbung geht ok was wollen
sie haben selbstorganisation sieht man ja schon bei mir im stream wie gut meine selbstorganisation
klappt bei uns gibt es kein mikro management und keine klassischen hier erschienen du
hast raum zum gestalten und wirken sponsor block genau sponsor block meine ich sponsor
block das meine ich hier das skippt auf youtube ads die quasi in die videos sind beste mache
ich aber hier nicht weil wenn ich hier werbung wenn ich hier videos gucke von anderen leuten
im stream dann sollen die auch ein bisschen was von haben und wenn sie werbung machen
machen sie halt werbung gestalten und wirken ist ja das ist ja so standard floskel stimmt
schon cross functional business analystanalysten developer ux designer key account manager
arbeiten an der anwendung bei uns auf augenhöhe ok team play echtes miteinander im team mit
freundlichen kollegen sowie gegenseite respekt und wertschätzung ein hohes maß an sozialer
kompetenz erwarten ich oje soziale kompetenz ist so was wo ich sagen muss nicht nur ich
sondern viele wirklich wirklich auch viele gute leute die ich kenne sei es jetzt entwickler
oder generell so aus der it da ist es mit sozialer kompetenz jetzt vielleicht nicht
so die der vorzeigeskill ich bin ja auch jemand der gerne nicht auf team events geht wenn
ich die auswahl habe ich war in chat chat ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist kann immer
nur für mich sprechen ja wenn ich die auswahl habe zwischen ich gehe nach der arbeit heim
setze ich noch mal an mein rechner und mache den stream an oder ich gehe auf sommerfest
von der arbeit dann gehe ich heim und mache den stream an und gehe nicht auf sommerfest
was heißt was heißt heimgehen und stream machen ich würde einfaches heimgehen und sachen
machen die ich machen will vorziehen auch ohne streamen und nicht auf sommerfest gehen
ja ich sehe bei euch ist es genauso
cs lsm sagt habe extra urlaub genommen um nicht beim grillen teilnehmen zu müssen also
leute ihr seid wirklich ich habe ich habe lange gebraucht bis ich das kapiert habe dass ich
nicht normal bin in der in der art und weise dass ich auf sowas gerne hingehe ich habe
immer gedacht ich habe sie nicht mehr all weil ich viele kollegen habe die gerne auf
solche events gehen habe ich mein max das ist doch irgendwie merkwürdig und so aber
mittlerweile habe ich kapiert es gibt ganz viele andere leute die auch kein bock haben
aber natürlich sind das nicht die leute wo du es direkt merkst ja und außerdem wo ich
auch eine weile für gebraucht habe ist und wo ich da habe ich wirklich eine ganze weile
für gebraucht es gibt ein paar sachen die wird jeder an sich feststellen die sind halt
nicht normal irgendwie ja also wenn er wenn er das sich vergleicht mit anderen leuten
oder mit vielen anderen leuten wird man denken irgendwie ist das und das an mir nicht normal
das hat aber jeder und ich habe eine weile gebraucht bis ich aufgehört habe daran rum
zu doktoren also bis ich bis ich aufgehört habe zu sagen ja ja ok probieren wir es doch
mal machen wir hier weil ich hatte nie bock irgendwie in dieser richtung was zu ändern
eigentlich aber ich habe immer gedacht man müsste manche sachen machen weil man sie halt
machen müsste aber unterm strich ist es für alle beteiligten einfacher wenn man sachen
nicht macht auf die man keinen bock hat also ich meine es nicht auf der arbeit wenn es
dein chef sagt kannst du mal kurz nachgucken du sagst alle ich habe keinen bock das meine
ich nicht wenn ihr keinen bock habt auf aufs after work grillen zu gehen dann geht einfach
nicht hin und am besten wenn man die leuten auch sagt man sagt hier hier das ist ist nicht
mein so events man kann sich natürlich auch versuchen rauszureden ja ich habe noch was
vor wenn man sagt hier so events ist nicht meins große ansammlung von leuten ist nicht
so das wo ich mich wohlfühle zu 99 prozent sagen die oder ach so ok wusste ich nicht
verstehe ich leuchten leuchten ja alles klar sehen wir uns morgen die haben keine problemen
die meister haben echt keine probleme manche leute denken eher wenn du dann mitgehst und
halt so den eindruck erweckt das hast du auf nix bock du magst sie nicht oder so wenn du
den leuten klar sagst irgendwie nee also ist echt nicht meins dann wissen die was sache
ist ja und wenn dann noch einer angepisst ist dann soll er halt angepisst sein aber
kannst du echt nichts dafür am besten am besten ist man sagt einfach und ich verstehe
das mit der sie verstehen das also die allermeisten leute verstehen das ja und eine sache wo ich
halt auch gemerkt habe bei mir ist alles mit mit mit sachen hier mit mit technik und so
nix zu tun dass ich absolut kein kein menschenfreund bin ich glaube das habe ich jetzt ganz gut
ausgedrückt ich kann andere leute nicht außer den chat natürlich der chat ist beste ja
aber ich mag einfach keine anderen leute ich flay mir öfters warum das mit kinder auf
den sack gehen im zug und so weil die so laut sind aber das ist nicht nur kinder mir gehen
alle menschen auf den keks alle bis auf ein paar ausnahmen deswegen verstehe ich mich
glaube ich mit dem fabian auch so gut ja mit dem fabian ist komisch also ich kann mit
dem fabian irgendwie ein halbes jahr nicht reden oder ein jahr nicht reden so nach dem
motto und irgendwann ist es uns bei meiner nacht dass wir sagen ruft mal discord an und
dann können wir drei stunden schwätzen als als hätten wir uns jeden tag als hätten wir
jeden tag xbox gespielt so nach dem motto ja und paar leute in paar leuten verstehe
ich mich ja aber ich mag die meisten leute schlicht und ergreifend nicht bei mir ist
es halt eher so die fault dass ich leute nicht mag und mit der zeit gibt es dann ein paar
die mag ich ich glaube bei den meisten anderen leute ist es umgedreht so nach dem motto sie
sind da eher sie mögen andere leute erst mal außer welche die sich total daneben benehmen
die mögen sie da nicht ja und dazu kommt bei mir auch noch das ist auch was wo ich lange
versucht habe dran rum zu doktorn bis ich irgendwie halt einfach gemerkt habe es ist
halt so so bin ich halt dass ich keine motivation habe was soziale kontakte angeht also sprich
wenn mich irgendjemand sagt hey gehen wir mal wieder was essen dann kann es durchaus
sein dass ich das dann irgendwie ignorieren so nach dem motto ach stimmt ja du hattest
ja was gesagt oder ihr erinnert euch noch vielleicht an das weihnachtsgrill von vor
zwei jahren das lag schlicht also ich habe das komplett verkackt ich war mir auch die
ganze zeit im klagen darüber dass ich das komplett verkackt habe aber wenn man sich
dann halt einfach irgendwie fünf wochen nicht meldet so ohne jeglichen ersichtlichen grund
da muss man sich nicht wundern wenn der oder die andere dann denkt da ist irgendwie hat
das nicht mal ja das hat eine weile gedauert bis ich das gecheckt habe ja genau tomox
er schreibt früher habe ich auch immer versucht so zu sein wie ich dachte wie man sein muss
ja das trifft dass die formulierung trifft eigentlich ganz muss man gar nicht das dauert
aber eine weile bis man bis man big brain genug ist das zu kapieren erst gibt es genug
leute die das ähnlich sehen wie man selbst nur erfährt man das meistens nicht und außerdem
ist das vollkommen in ordnung die anderen sollen auch alle machen was sie wollen und
machen können was sie wollen dann soll das bei uns auch so sein endless dimension sagt
soziale erwartungen sind viel zu groß an junge leute oder allgemein was meinst du denn mit
sozialer erwartung an junge leute so ja gut ist lange genug hier rumgeklickt ich wollte
eigentlich auf warzone spielen sind eigentlich meine teammates am start in warzone mal kurz
gucken auch hat ganze zwei zuschauer poggers wie viel schon vier wins ja die haben vier
wins weil ich nicht mitspiele wenn ich mitspiele hätten sie kein win aber mittlerweile gehts
ja mittlerweile muss ich nicht mal ganz so hart gecarriert werden es ist wirklich hart
ich habe ja jahrelang nix mal wirklich shooter mäßiges gespielt und ich habe jetzt bestimmt
zwei wochen gebraucht bis ich wieder recht recht okay reingekommen bin was hältst du
von valorant nie selbst gespielt ich finde gut dass valorant mehr oh mr robot bypassing
windows echt in season 4 haben die mal wieder was technisch mäßiges gezeigt mr robot
ist doch nach der nach der hälfte der erste staffel mehr psychogramm vom hält als technik
gewesen deswegen habe ich auch nicht weiter geguckt genau valorant ich finde gut dass
valorant mehr zerst ist als overwatch so siehts aus okay leute vier stunden fast geschwätzt
es reicht jetzt ich hauste mal den ich hauste mal den vetrus und es kann sein dass ich
gleich am start bin hier im stream bei ihnen und wir noch ne runde ne runde warthorn spielen
ich stream heute kein gott vier stunden gelabert reicht mir wir raiden ihn mal er kann er kann
wirklich jeden zuschauer gebrauchen zwei zuschauer das ist ja nix okay ich mach mal
den raid an ihr könnt ja einfach mal vorbei gucken irgendwas sinnloses in chats spammen
und dann sehen wir uns morgen früh morgen früh bin ich wieder am start also aufwacht
stream morgen früh bis denn wir sehen uns zu